With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver. And with Instacart's in-store prices at select stores, you can do more this winter without paying more. So double down on your shortbread production without upping the price. Add more chilies to your chili without the added sting. Go completely ham on candy DMs and celebrate the season of being extra without paying extra. So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Instacart. Groceries that over-deliver.
使用 Instacart，您可以买到物超所值的杂货。通过 Instacart 在指定门店的店内价，这个冬天您无需花更多钱就能享受更多乐趣。因此，您可以在不涨价的情况下加倍制作酥饼。在辣椒里添加更多辣椒，却没有辣到刺痛的感觉。疯狂采购糖果的私信，庆祝这个不花冤枉钱却能享受极致体验的季节。今天就下载应用程序，前三笔订单即可享受 0 美元配送费。Instacart。物超所值的杂货。
Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello there.
服务费、不适用情况和条款适用。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为您带来终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将深入探讨《办公室》的世界，提供独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是“办公室女士”6.0 版。大家好。
Hi there. Oh there. Ah. This is nice. studio. This is our first in-studio recording since I went to Chicago. I know. It's been months, ladies. I know. I like being in real life with you. I know in the IRL life. Yes. I'm also really excited about today's episode. I am too because it's just joy. It's what it is. If you want a little bit of joy in your life, you're here. You're at the right spot. This is our fan appreciation episode.
大家好。哦，大家好。啊。这个工作室真不错。这是我去芝加哥以来我们第一次在工作室录制节目。我知道。好几个月了，女士们。我知道。我喜欢和你们在现实生活中见面。我知道，在 IRL（现实生活）中。是的。我对今天的节目也感到非常兴奋。我也是，因为它纯粹带来快乐。这就是它的意义所在。如果你想在生活中寻找一点快乐，你来对地方了。你找对地方了。这是我们的粉丝感谢特辑。
We are going to share about getting to meet all of you at the office convention and at the stage door of Ashland Avenue. But before we do that, Angela, you said you have a special fan appreciation shout out. I really do. I'm so tickled by this. And the first shout out I want to goes to an office ladies fan that works on the television game show, Jeopardy. So here's the thing. Katie is her name, Katie Ruskus. She reached out. She is the office production assistant at Jeopardy. And she wanted to tell us that Office Ladies was going to be a question on Jeopardy. I can't believe it. And as I began to trade messages with her, I found out that her dad is a huge Office Ladies fan. Shout out to Chris, her dad. Hi, Chris. And her dad got Katie listening
我们将分享在办公室粉丝见面会以及阿什兰大道舞台门口与大家见面的经历。但在我们这样做之前，安吉拉，你说你有一个特别的粉丝感谢鸣谢。我真的有。我对此感到非常高兴。我想发出的第一个鸣谢是给一位在电视游戏节目《危险边缘》工作的“办公室女士”粉丝。事情是这样的。她叫凯蒂，凯蒂·拉斯库斯。她联系了我们。她是《危险边缘》的办公室制作助理。她想告诉我们，“办公室女士”将成为《危险边缘》里的一个问题。我真不敢相信。当我开始与她互发信息时，我发现她的父亲是“办公室女士”的超级粉丝。向克里斯致敬，她的父亲。嗨，克里斯。她父亲让凯蒂开始收听
to Office Ladies, and now they listen to it together. I love that. Is that adorable? Yes. Katie is such a delight. So the episode already came out. Yes. This aired on October 22nd. We have a clip. This is how we appear. on Jeopardy. Give it a listen. Television for 12. A podcast episode from Office Ladies debated whether or not this character in HR from the office was the Scranton Strangler. Tom. Who's Toby? Right. Isn't that so cool? Yes, I mean, that's really cool. I remember when I was the answer in one of the like people crossword puzzles. So fun. And now Jeopardy. I know. It's the big time. It's the big
《办公室女士》，现在他们一起收听。我太喜欢了。是不是很可爱？是的。凯蒂太讨人喜欢了。所以那一集已经播出了。是的。这期节目于 10 月 22 日播出。我们有一个片段。这就是我们在《危险边缘》中出场的方式。听一听。电视类 12 分。“办公室女士”的一集播客讨论了《办公室》里的这位人事部门角色是否是斯克兰顿扼喉手。汤姆。谁是托比？对。是不是很酷？是的，我的意思是，这真的很酷。我记得当我在某个人字填字游戏里作为答案的时候。太有趣了。现在是《危险边缘》。我知道。这是大场面
time. Well, you know, my grandmother watched Jeopardy every day. And I just think she would have been so thrilled with this. And if that wasn't cool enough, the folks at Jeopardy sent us each a framed copy of our Jeopardy question and the day it aired. I have one for each of you guys. We'll get a picture and share it. But how fun. I love it. Well, thank you, Katie, and please thank your dad for listening to the podcast. Now we're going to get into some stories about the office fan convention. Yeah, you know what? This was a really fun road trip that Cassie and I took. It was this past August. It was the big, big, the office fan convention in New Jersey. Well, we should tell everyone that I couldn't go to the office fan convention because I was in Chicago rehearsing my play. But like you said, you and Cassie did go together. Yeah, it was Cassie's first The Office Convention. And everyone was so lovely. We got to meet a ton of people. And there were a lot of Office Ladies fans there.
。你知道，我奶奶每天都看《危险边缘》。我只是觉得她会对这件事感到非常兴奋。如果这还不够酷的话，《危险边缘》的工作人员给我们每个人寄了一份我们那个《危险边缘》问题的装裱副本以及播客播出的日期。我给你们每人都准备了一份。我们会拍张照分享出来。但多有趣啊。我太喜欢了。好吧，谢谢凯蒂，也请谢谢你的爸爸收听这个播客。现在我们要讲一些关于办公室粉丝见面会的故事。是的，你知道吗？这是我和卡西进行的一次非常有趣的公路旅行。那是去年八月。那是新泽西州规模盛大、无与伦比的办公室粉丝见面会。好吧，我们应该告诉大家，我没能去办公室粉丝见面会，因为我在芝加哥排练我的戏剧。但就像你说的，你和卡西确实一起去了。是的，这是卡西第一次参加办公室粉丝见面会。每个人都太可爱了。我们遇到了超多的人。那里有很多“办公室女士”的粉丝。
Well, lady, I got to meet so many Office Ladies fans at the stage door for Ashland Avenue. Isn't it so fun? Because they say, lady, and you know right away. I do. If someone said Lady, I knew they listened to Office Ladies. But yeah, after each performance, I would come out. And so I think we had like 39 performances of Ashland Avenue, and I was able to come out 37 times. That's fantastic, because I've been to plays. People don't come out. I'm just saying. I know. That's really great. There were two I wasn't allowed to come out for. So if you were at those performances, I apologize.
好吧，女士，我在阿什兰大道的舞台门口遇到了超多“办公室女士”的粉丝。是不是很有趣？因为他们会说“女士”，而你马上就能认出来。我确实知道。如果有人说“女士”，我就知道他们听过“办公室女士”。但是，是的，每次演出结束后，我都会出来。所以我想我们大概演了 39 场《阿什兰大道》，而我成功出来了 37 次。这太棒了，因为我去过戏剧演出现场。人们根本不会出来。我只是随口说说。我知道。这真的很棒。有两场演出我不被允许出来。所以如果你当时在现场观看那几场演出，我向你们道歉。
They don't do a stage door after opening night because there's this special event immediately following and they want the cast and crew to get there quickly. And also one day after a matinee, a man fell down the stairs in the lobby and they had to call an ambulance and they had to clear the lobby so I wasn't allowed to come out. He's okay. Okay, good. But lady, I have to share a story because a few times, I was. was on vocal rest because my voice with eight shows a week, it was getting strained and I would have these big weekends with so many shows in a row. So they said, you can do the stage door, but you can't speak. And so they would send this gal Lauren out to the crowd. And she would explain that I was on
首演之夜结束后他们不会在舞台门口停留，因为紧接着有一个特别活动，他们希望演员和剧组人员能迅速赶到那里。还有一天，在日场演出结束后，有个男的在门厅的楼梯上摔倒了，他们不得不叫救护车，还不得不清空门厅，所以我没被允许出去。他没事。好的，很好。但是，女士，我得分享一个故事，因为有几次，我在保护嗓子，因为我一周有八场演出，我的嗓音开始有些吃不消，而且我会迎来那种连续有好多场演出的超忙周末。所以他们说，你可以去舞台门口，但你不能说话。于是他们会派这个叫劳伦的姑娘去人群中。她会向大家解释我在保护嗓子，但如果大家准备好相机或者准备好钢笔，我会出来拍照并签名。这真的非常搞笑，因为每次我出来的时候，平时我从舞台门口出来时，大家都会“嘿，耶”，而且大家为从舞台门口出来的每一位演员欢呼的样子真的太甜了。但如果那是嗓音休息日，当我打开门时，大家就会“嗨”，就好像人群也在保护嗓子一样，太可爱了。然后当我与大家互动时，人们也会耳语或者像是在模仿。这是人们非常自然的举动，因为甚至当我打电话给你时，因为你说“我不能说话，但你可以说话”，然后我会说“嘿”。是的。这算是在干嘛呢？我知道，完全是这样。我能说话。
vocal rest, but if people got their cameras ready or if they had their pens ready, that I was going to come take pictures and sign things. And it was just very funny because every time I came out, normally I would come out the stage door and people would be like hey yay and it was so sweet they would cheer for every cast member who came out the stage door but if it was a vocal rest day when I opened the door people would go hi as if the crowd was also on vocal rest it's so cute and then when I would interact with people they would whisper as well or like mime it's such a natural thing that people do because even when I called you because you were like I can't talk but you can talk and I be like, hey. Yes. Like, what am I doing? I know, exactly. I can talk.
但那只是其中一个故事。我有好多故事。不过，女士，你先说。好吧，嗯，这简直暖到了我的心坎里。只要想象一下所有那些人在外面等你。你知道，我也想分享的是，乔希和我在我们的烹饪书巡回签售会上遇到了那么多棒极了的“办公室女士”粉丝。我太感动了。
But that's just one story. I have so many stories. But lady, you start. Okay, well, that just warms my heart. Just picturing all those people out there waiting for you. You know, I also want to share that Josh and I met so many wonderful office ladies folks on our cookbook tour. I was so moved.
我太感动了，人们大老远赶来支持我们以及我们出烹饪书的梦想。是的，这真的很特别。有一位女士给我带了一个篮子。就像一个包，你知道的，我爱篮子。哦，就因为你爱篮子。里面什么都没有。里面什么都没有。
I was so moved that people traveled far distances just to support us and our dream of having a cookbook. And yeah, it was really special. one lady brought me a basket. Like a bag, you know, I love baskets. Oh, just because you love a basket. Nothing in it. Nothing in it.
她的名字叫奥拉，她说：“我支持你对篮子的这份热爱。”但你猜怎么着？我们在里面塞了一大堆东西。你当然会这么做。不管怎样，我想要从办公室粉丝见面会开始讲起。是的，我很想听听这些故事。所以，首先，对我和卡西来说，她能去真的特别棒，因为卡西和萨姆是我们“办公室女士”大家庭中非常重要的一部分。
Her name was Orla, and she was like, I support this passion of yours for baskets. But then guess what? We put a bunch of stuff in it. Of course you did. Anyway, I want to start right now with the office fan convention. Yes, I want to hear these stories. So, for one, for me, it was really special that Cassie got to go because Cassie and Sam are such a big part of our office ladies' family.
当我说“卡西在这儿”时，好多人都高兴坏了。他们说：“卡西？”然后他们又问：“萨姆呢？”他们说：“我们需要萨姆。”坊间传闻，萨姆，你也喜欢粉丝见面会。所以他们正等着你在各种活动上露面呢。但对于那些没去过粉丝见面会的人，我曾试图向我姐姐描述它。你知道，那是人们在喜欢电影和电视节目时去的地方，你可以见到电影里的人，那里还有各种各样的精美周边。天哪，如果你喜欢周边的话。但这次专门是为办公室粉丝举办的。里面没有来自漫威电影的人，只有办公室这个大家庭。那种充满正能量和奇妙感觉的氛围太深厚了。我有一个展位，你知道的，会有那种人们排队等着见你的展位。我的展位就在雷恩·威尔逊的隔壁。我们中间隔着一块帘子，他一直掀开帘子对我大喊大叫。
and so many people were so tickled when I was like, Cassie's here. They're like, Cassie? And then they were like, where's Sam? And they were like, we need Sam. Word is on the street, Sam, also that you like conventions. So they're ready for you to turn up at things. But for those of you that haven't been to a convention, I was trying to describe it to my sister. You know, that's where people go when you're fans of movies and TV shows and you can meet people
比如，你话是不是太多了？快点。他就像是一整天都在拿我开涮。真的超级搞笑。但你能在那里遇到来自全美各地，老实说，甚至是世界各地的人。他们会与你分享《办公室》对他们意味着什么。而且日程安排是有一定结构的。所以你会有一条排队见粉丝的队伍。但随后你也会抽空去和演员阵容的不同组合进行合影。那些真的太好玩了。所以你会拍一张大合照。但接着他们会说：“好吧，现在拍一张只有会计师们的合照。”所以合照里就会有我和奥斯卡、布莱恩。然后还有一个粉丝？是的，然后他们会插进来。好的。然后还会问：“好吧，有人想要一张和德怀特、安吉拉的合照吗？”然后我们就有了所有这些“德怀特-安吉拉”的粉丝，向我的“德怀特-安吉拉”粉丝们致敬。
in the movies and there's all kinds of great merch. Oh my gosh, if you love merch. but this one was specifically just for the office fans. Like there weren't people from the Marvel movies or it's just the office community. And the energy was so profoundly positive and wonderful. I had a booth, you know, you have booths where people can wait in line to meet you. Mine was right next to Rain Wilson. We had a curtain between us and he kept opening the curtain and yelling things at me.
所以你们拍完照之后，就会有一个问答环节，全体演员都会上台，由粉丝们提问。对，对。女士，我发了一段视频在那个问答环节播放，因为我没能去现场。他们把视频剪辑在了一起。太可爱了。向“办公室联盟”（The Office Alliance）的马特致敬。那是一个Instagram账号。里面全都是关于《办公室》的内容。他真的帮了很多忙
Like, do you talk too much? Speed it up. He was like, kind of like giving me shit all day. It was really funny. But you meet people from all over the United States and honestly, all over the world. And they share with you what the office has meant to them. And the day is kind of structured. So you have this line where you meet people. But then you also pop off and you go do photo ops with different configurations of the cast. And those are so fun. So you do a big group photo. But then they were like, okay, now one just with the accountants. So it would be me and Oscar and Brian. And then a fan as well? Yes, and then they pop in. Okay. And then it will say, okay, does anyone want a picture with Dwight and Angela? And so then we have all these Dwayangela fans, which shout out to my Dwayangela people.
把你的视频剪辑到了一起。是的。大家超喜欢。耶。你一出现在屏幕上那一刻，我真希望当时有观众的视频，因为他们都在喊“耶，珍娜来了”。啊，我太高兴了。我一直很喜欢做《办公室》的问答环节。就像，我很喜欢那些问答。我知道。是的，真的很有趣。大家总能提出最棒的问题。但我确实要分享一个来自问答环节的可爱、有趣的小瞬间。当时有个粉丝提问说，你知道的，节目里有没有哪个瞬间让你感到紧张之类的。
And so you do that. And then you have a Q&A panel, and the whole cast gets up there and fans ask questions. Yes, yes. Lady, I sent in a video to play during that panel because I couldn't be there. And they edited it together. It was so cute. Well, shout out to Matt. from the Office Alliance. It's an Instagram account. That's all things the office. He really helped
然后我分享了我其实不喜欢在别人面前唱歌，你知道的。接着突然间我不得不在全体演员面前演唱《小鼓手男孩》。是的。以及我是多么紧张。于是我站起来，雷恩和我重现了那个瞬间。你真的照做了。是的。
put your video together. Yeah. People loved it. Yay. The minute you popped up on the screen, I wish I had video of the audience because they were like, yay, Jenna's here. Aw, I'm so glad. I always love doing the office panels. Like, I like those Q&As. I know. Yeah, they're really fun. People always have the best questions. But I do have to share one cute, fun moment from the Q&A panel. So a fan had asked a question about, you know, there's a moment where you got nervous on the show or something like that.
他单膝跪地，唱起了“pa-pum-pum-bum”，整套动作都做出来了。太可爱了。大家喜欢吗？大家简直疯狂了。我想应该有视频，我会分享出来的。呃。在见面会的周六，
And I shared how I don't like to sing in front of people, you know. And then all of a sudden I had to sing the little drummer boy in front of the whole entire cast. Yes. And how I was really nervous. So I got up and Rain and I recreated the moment. You did. Yes.
有超过 7,000 人到来。是不是很惊人？人真的很多。很大一部分演员和我们的一些剧组工作人员都来了。太惊人了。多么有趣的经历。所以不仅有《办公室》演员之间、剧组工作人员之间以及喜爱这部剧的粉丝之间所有这些非常棒的互动，而且这些粉丝见面会对于热爱《办公室》并创作《办公室》粉丝艺术的艺术家们来说，也是一个绝佳的机会，
And he dropped to his knee and did the pabra bum, the whole thing. It was so cute. Did people love it? People went nuts. I think there's video. of it that I'll share. Ugh. On Saturday of the convention,
包括纹身师。女士，你可以在粉丝见面会上纹身。等等，是临时纹身还是永久纹身？不，是真正的纹身。而且它们全都是办公室主题的，比如“拯救班迪特”（Save Bandit），或者“监狱迈克”（Prison Mike）纹身，或者邓迪奖杯（Dundee），或者茶壶，或者安吉拉·马丁那种带点傲娇风格的纹身。我的意思是，我遇到了好多带有《办公室》灵感纹身的人。它们太棒了。我拍了几张照片，但我最喜欢的是我遇到的一位女士，她的脚肚上有一个纹身。
over 7,000 people came. Is that amazing? That's a lot. A huge amount of the cast came and some of our crew. That's so amazing. What a fun experience. So not only do you have all of this
纹的是一辆火车。火车上有一个标志，上面写着“慢”。然后标志旁边写着“费城”，就像你要进费城一样，但你坐的是慢车。是的。太棒了。我会把它发到我们的动态里。好吧，女士，我知道你很喜欢看别人的《办公室》纹身。你经常给我发短信，说你遇到了谁，对方还给你看他们的《办公室》纹身。我的意思是，我真的觉得这太着迷了。人们竟然那么喜欢这部剧，甚至去纹身。好吧，当我在舞台门口遇到大家时，如果他们给我看《办公室》纹身，我会问是否可以拍张照，然后发给你。你确实这么做了。
really great engagement between the cast of the office, the crew of the office, and fans that love the show, but these conventions are also an amazing opportunity for artists that love the office and do the office fan art,
我确实有一个最喜欢的。好吧。我想那是某个人纹了一个小热狗，上面写着：“嗨，你好啊，伙计。”“嗨，你好啊，伙计。”是的。但还有一位女士，她的整条胳膊，也就是整条花臂，全都是《办公室》的纹身。我拍了一段视频。我说：“如果我拍一段你胳膊的视频发给安吉拉，会显得很奇怪吗？”
including tattoo artists. Lady, you could get a tattoo at the convention. Wait, like a temporary tattoo or a permanent tattoo? No, a real tattoo. And they would be all office themes, like Save Bandit or a Prison Mike tattoo or a Dundee or a teapot or like a tattoo with Angela Martin that's like sassy. I mean, I met so many people that had office-inspired tattoos. They were amazing. I took a few pictures, but my favorite was this lady I met who had a tattoo on her calf.
她说：“不会。”这太不可思议了。好吧，卡西能够四处走动去各个展位。我呢，有点，你知道的，被困在我的队伍里了。所以我没能好好探索一番。她拍了好多照片和视频。卡西其实现在就和我们一起在工作室里。卡西，你见到了很多人，并问了他们对《办公室》和“办公室女士”的热爱，你还收集了所有这些音频剪辑。
of a train. And the train had a sign on it that says slow. And then next to the sign, it said, Philly, like you're coming into Philly, but you're on the slow train. Yes. It was so awesome. I'll put it in our stories. Well, lady, I know that you love seeing people's office tattoos. You often send me text messages of people you've met who have showed you their office tattoos. I mean, I find it so fascinating. People love the show that much. They get a tattoo. Well, when I met people at the stage door, if they showed me an office tattoo, I would ask if I could take a photo and then I sent them to you. You did.
你花了好多时间。这真的很棒。我们今天会分享其中的一些。但在我们开始播放之前，我想知道你能否跟我们简单聊聊你在粉丝见面会上的经历。好的，当然。能见到所有这些“办公室女士”的粉丝和《办公室》的粉丝真的太美妙了，并且能真切感受到他们对这部剧和播客的热情。而且，是的，我和好多人聊过。我带着一个小话筒。
I did have a favorite. Okay. I think it was someone that got the little hot dog that said, hi, you, buddy. Hi, you, buddy. Yes. But there was also a woman who had a whole arm, like a sleeve of all office tattoos. I took a video. I was like, would it be weird if I took a video of your arm so I can send it to Angela?
你真的带了。你甚至有自己的专属队伍。我转头看过去，然后，我遇到了一些人，接着他们会走过来，我们会问：“你想和卡西打个招呼吗？”我觉得几乎每个人都说好。对。几乎每个人都答应了。所以要挑选我最喜欢的剪辑真的很难，因为我都太喜欢了。
She was like, no, it was incredible. Well, Cassie was able to walk around to all the different booths. I was sort of, you know, a little bit stuck in my line. So I didn't get to explore quite as much. And she took a lot of pictures and videos. And Cassie is actually in here in the studio with us. And Cassie, you got to meet a lot of people and ask them about their love for the office and office ladies. And you compiled all these audio clips.
不过有一个剪辑我觉得很适合作为开场。好的，太好了。萨姆，我们能听听吗？雪莉和伊丽莎白。嗨。来自康涅狄格州。不错。是的。办公室对你们意味着什么？
You spent a lot of time. It was really wonderful. We're going to share some of them today. But before we start playing them, I was wondering if you could tell us a little bit about your experience at the convention. Yeah, of course. It was so nice meeting all these, like, office ladies fans and office fans and, like, really feeling how passionate they are for the show and the podcast. And, yeah, I talked to so many people. I had, like, a little microphone.
轻松。她现在每天都给办公室带来轻松。是的，字面意思上，我再也不准说“她也这么说”了。是的。等等，你们两个一起工作吗？是的，我们一起工作，而且是最好的朋友。哦，天哪。太酷了。
You did. You had your own line. I looked over. And, like, I would meet people and then they'd go over and we'd be like, do you want to say hi to Cassie? I feel like almost everybody said yes. Yeah. Pretty much everyone did. So it was really hard to, like, pick my favorite clips because I loved them all.
这就像是《办公室》和《办公室女士》的结合体。啊。雪莉和伊丽莎白。她们是一起工作的闺蜜。太甜了。不过我喜欢她们有规矩这一点。你们不能说“她也这么说”。我想作为开场的另一个片段是朱莉娅的这段话，她是一个超级“办公室女士”粉丝。
But there is one that I think is a good to start with. Okay, great. Can we hear it, Sam? Cheryl and Elizabeth. Hi. From Connecticut. Nice. Yep. And what does the office mean to you?
太棒了。我叫朱莉娅。你穿的是什么？我有茶壶耳环。我有帕姆的装扮。然后，当然还有我的播客周边，我的围巾。你有没有最喜欢的“办公室女士”单集或某个瞬间？我喜欢那集精彩的
Levity. And she brings Levity to the office every day now. Yeah, I literally am not allowed to say that's what she said anymore. Yeah. Wait, do you two work together? And we do it in her best friends. Oh, my God. That's so cool.
游轮集，格雷格·丹尼尔斯在里面谈到，你知道的，人们嘴上说自己在做什么与实际在做什么之间的对比，以及如何识破这一点。你在播客里学到了太多东西。《办公室》对你意味着什么？《办公室》就是我的家，当我在周三的散步途中听播客时，我感觉最像我自己。耶。每当我听到有人分享他们是在散步途中或者通勤路上收听（你知道的）播客时，就会知道我们为他们填补了那段时间，并且我们成了他们的
It's like the office and office ladies combined. Aw. Cheryl and Elizabeth. They're BFFs that work together. It's so sweet. I like that they have rules, though. You can't say that's what she's saying. The other clip I wanted to start off with is this clip from Julia, who is a huge office lady's fan.
快乐源泉，我太喜欢了。安吉拉，我觉得她穿了这么多我们的周边真的太可爱了，因为你在上面付出了那么多心血。我确实很喜欢周边，当我看到任何人穿着“办公室女士”的卫衣或任何相关物品时，我真的会变成狂热粉丝。我总是会去评论。好吧，在舞台门口，人们会穿着我们的周边，还有纹身。如果有人穿着我们的周边，我就会问能不能拍张照片发给你。有个女士穿着我们的“办公室女士”围裙。我们的围裙女士，那是时光倒流啊。我知道。我想她叫维拉，她还送了我一些来自圣路易斯的黏稠黄油蛋糕。
Great. My name's Julia. And what are you wearing? So I've got my teapot earrings. I've got the pams. And then, of course, my podcast merch here, my scarf. Do you have a favorite office ladies episode or a moment? I love the big.
所以谢谢你，维拉。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来后，我们将分享更多来自粉丝见面会和舞台门口的故事，一些非常惊人的粉丝偶遇经历，包括我和卡西要给大家讲一个关于一对情侣在粉丝见面会上结婚的故事。在粉丝见面会上？是的，而且可能还有一位《办公室》演员担任了证婚人。哦，天哪。
cruise episode where Greg Daniels talks about, you know, what are people saying they're doing versus what they're doing and how to catch that. You learned so much on the podcast. What does the office mean to you? The office is home, and I feel most like myself when I'm listening to the podcast on my Wednesday walk. Yay. Every time I hear when someone shares that they listen to the, you know, podcast on their walk or in their commute and just know that we feel that time for them and we're having.
我们马上回来。假期即将来临，这意味着这是利用 Rakuten 节省开支的绝佳时机。使用 Rakuten 在您最喜爱的商店叠加节日大促销获取现金返还。这就是省上加省。通过 Rakuten，您可以为清单上的每个人采购的礼物赚取现金返还，从孩子们的玩具，到送给热爱烹饪之人的厨房装备，再到送给每个人的电子产品。您甚至可以省下买给自己的礼物钱。只需在您喜爱的商店购物，现金返还会自动添加到您的账户中，并且您可以选择通过 Interact 电子转账、PayPal 或支票获得付款。今天免费加入，并在完成最低符合条件的购买后获得新会员奖金。
happy place for them. I love it so much. I think it's so sweet that she was wearing so much of our merch, Angela, because you work so hard on it. I do love merch, and when I see anyone in an office lady's sweatshirt or anything, I do geek out. I always comment on it. Well, at the stage door, people would wear our merch and like the tattoos. If anybody was wearing our merch, I asked if I could take a picture and send it to you. One woman wore our office lady's apron. Our apron lady, That's traveling back in time. I know. I believe her name was Vera, and she also gave me some gooey butter cake from St. Louis.
只需访问 rakuten.ca。下载应用程序或安装浏览器扩展程序。拼写是 R-A-K-U-T-E-N，条款和条件适用。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。所以我们来了。假期到了。假期是传统的代名词。我想当你想起假期传统时，你通常会想到，哦，我们要怎么装饰？怎么交换礼物？但我想知道我们是否应该为假期添点新传统，那就是自我关怀的传统。哦，我喜欢这个。对吧？是的。因为这可能是一段忙碌而混乱的时期。绝对的。而且它也可能是一个
So thank you, Vera. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to share some more stories from the convention and the stage door, some really amazing fan encounters, including Cassie and I have a story for you about a couple that got married at the convention. At the convention? Yes, and there might have been an office cast member that officiated. Oh, my goodness.
孤独的时期，你知道的？是的，在假期里优先坚持自我关怀的传统。我觉得我们需要把这个加到清单里。我真的很喜欢这个。好吧，你知道的，在假期里你可能需要应付很多人，而心理治疗可以成为你学习积极应对技巧、如何重置界限或者只是设定界限并赋予自己力量以成为最好的自己的途径。因此，不妨考虑在 12 月尝试 BetterHelp 在线心理治疗，以此来带着清晰而非混乱的心情结束这一年。这个今年 12 月，通过照顾好自己来开启一项新传统。我们的听众在 betterhelp.com slash office ladies 可以享受 9 折优惠。
We'll be right back. The holidays are here, and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save with Racketon. Use Racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales. That's savings on savings. With Rackaton, you can get cash back on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids, to kitchen gear, for the person who loves to cook, to electronics for everyone. You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love and cashback is automatically added to your account and you can choose to get paid via Interact-E Transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases.
网址是 better h-e-l-p.com slash office ladies。好了，我们回来了，珍娜，卡西和我有一个很棒的故事要讲给大家听。这是《办公室》粉丝见面会上破天荒头一次有两个人结婚。嗯哼。安迪·巴克利担任了证婚人。大卫·华莱士。嗯哼。太惊人了。
Just go to rackettin.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N, Terms and Conditions Apply. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So here we are. It's the holidays. Holidays are a time of traditions. I think when you think of holiday tradition, you're usually thinking about, oh, how do we decorate? How do we exchange gifts? But I wonder if we should add something a new tradition to the holidays, which is the tradition of self-care. Oh, I like that. Right? Yeah. Because it can be a hectic and chaotic time. Absolutely. And also it can be a
所以，扮演德怀特的角色扮演者瑞恩，与他的未婚妻科拉结婚了，科拉也是个角色扮演者，为了这场婚礼，他们俩分别打扮成了安吉拉·马丁和德怀特·舒鲁特。嗯哼。太惊人了。对于你们这些没去过粉丝见面会的听众来说，角色扮演非常流行。人们打扮成自己最喜欢的角色。他们会全力以赴。是的。
lonely time, you know? Yes, and prioritizing the tradition of self-care at the holidays. I feel like we need to add that to the list. I really like that. Well, you know, you're probably having to deal with a lot of folks around the holidays, and therapy can be a way for you to learn positive coping skills, how to reset your boundaries or just set your boundaries and empower yourself to be the best version of yourself. So consider trying better help online therapy in December as a way to close the year with clarity rather than chaos. This December, start a new tradition by taking care of you. Our listeners get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies.
是的，瑞恩甚至预定了一个展位，他搭建了一个德怀特的桌子，上面有德怀特的小铭牌、电脑电话，还有一个里面装着订书机的果冻模具。这太酷了，大家可以在那个桌子旁和他合影。我很喜欢跟他聊天，这里有一段他的音频片段，讲述了他最终如何在周日早上的粉丝见面会上结婚的经过。所以我有计划今年结婚。其实我去年是在“怪咖阿尔”（Weird Al）演出前求婚的。我让他参与了求婚过程。他帮了我一把。大约一个半月前，我联系了安迪·巴克利，并没有抱什么期望。
That's better, h-e-l-p.com slash office ladies. All right, we are back, and Jenna, Cassie and I have quite a story for you all. It was the first time ever at the office convention that two people got married. Mm-hmm. Andy Buckley was the officiate. David Wallace. Uh-huh. Amazing.
我只是说，嘿，你有兴趣吗？就像，这是最后的重聚，我真的想做点特别的事。我本来就计划要结婚。这将是我们相遇两周年纪念日。你觉得你有兴趣在重聚活动上为我们证婚吗？我本以为他会说，你知道的，我深感荣幸。你想到了我。我其实没有时间。
So Ryan, a Dwight cosplayer, got married to his fiance, Cora, who is also a cosplayer, and for the wedding, the two of them dressed up as Angela Martin and Dwight Shrewd. Uh-huh. Amazing. And for any of you guys listening who haven't been to conventions, cosplaying is very popular. People dress up as their favorite characters. They go all out. Yeah.
你知道的，恭喜你们。希望你们俩生活美满。但他对此表现得非常非常兴奋。感觉他可能和我们一样兴奋。然后他去让自己接受了按立。而且，是的，他和我们一样迫不及待地期待那一天的到来。是的。这太惊人了。
Yeah, and Ryan even reserved a booth, and he set up a Dwight desk, and it had Dwight's little placard and computer phone, a jello mold with a stapler in it. And it was so cool, people could take pictures with him at the desk. And I love talking with him, and here's a clip of him explaining how he ended up getting married at the convention on Sunday morning. So I had plans to get married this year. I actually proposed in front of Weird Al last year. I made him part of the proposal. He kind of helped me out. About a month and a half ago, I reached out to Andy Buckley, not expecting anything.
我为你们所有人都感到兴奋。有好几个人过来对我说，嘿，你应该去跟他聊聊，因为他们要在粉丝见面会上结婚。这简直成了这个周末的超级热门话题。我的意思是，我们要拍成吨的照片。你打算在结婚时进行角色扮演，还是做你自己？哦，不。我们要扮演德怀特和安吉拉。
I just said, hey, would you be interested? Like, it's the last reunion, and I really want to do something special. I'm planning on getting married anyway. It'll be the two-year anniversary of when we met. Do you think you would be interested in marrying us at the reunion? And I expected him to say, you know, I'm really honored. You thought of me. I don't really have the time.
我今晚要用泡沫板和胶带做一个临时的棺材。那就是我们结婚时要站进去的东西，因为在坚硬的粉丝见面会地板上，这已经是你能做到的极限了，你知道的。哦，天哪。我知道，对吧？哇。太惊人了。安迪·巴克利能一口答应“这事包在我身上，我为你们而来”，这真是太棒了。
You know, congratulations. I hope you too have a great life. But he got very, very excited about it. Like, he might be as excited about it as we are. And went and got himself ordained. And, yeah, he can't wait for the day just like us. Yeah. It's so amazing.
那天我能够早点到达，他们一结完婚就在拍所有的结婚照，我和他们合了影。太棒了。他们还有两个伴郎，分别打扮成莫斯和迈克尔·斯科特。哇。太酷了。你也拍照了吗？
I'm so excited for you all. Several people have come up to me and, like, you should come talk to him because they're getting married here at the convention. Like, it is a huge buzz this weekend. I mean, we're going to press tons of photos. Are you planning to cosplay as you get married, or will you be yourself? Oh, no. We're going to be Dwight and Angela.
你能把它发到动态里吗？对，我绝对会发的。但很多人都打扮成不同的办公室角色。帮我负责展位的其中一个姑娘，贝蒂·让，她人最好了。她告诉我，她第一次参加粉丝见面会时扮演的是帕姆。萨姆，你在粉丝见面会上也做过角色扮演，虽然我有点害怕问这个问题，但你愿意分享一些你曾经扮演过的角色吗？我知道“巨乳甘道夫”是一个。
I'm, tonight, I'm using phone board and duct tape to make a makeshift coffin. And that's what we're going to be standing in when we're married, because that's the best you can do on a hard convention floor, you know. Oh, my gosh. I know, right? Wow. It's amazing. And how great that Andy Buckley was just like, I got this. I'm here for you.
那是那个角色的官方名字吗？是的，“巨乳甘道夫”就是那个角色的名字。我个人最喜欢的是，我去见布鲁斯·坎贝尔时扮演了《鬼玩人》里的艾什。上周末我见蒂姆·库瑞时，打扮成了《小丑回魂》里的乔治，少了一只胳膊，还穿着带血的雨衣。除此之外，我想这些就是我最喜欢的了。你有没有去粉丝见面会的计划？你接下来还有要参加的吗？
I was able to arrive early that. day, and they were doing all their wedding photos right after they got married, and I took pictures with them. Amazing. And they had two best men who were dressed as Moes and Michael Scott. Wow. That is so cool. You got pictures, too?
有的。我一月份要去见罗伯特·英格兰，他曾在《猛鬼街》里扮演弗莱迪·克鲁格，同一天还要见“方兹”（The Fonz）。所以我打算尝试打扮成方兹的造型。你要去见亨利·温克勒？对，我要去。你知道他是整个地球上最好的人吗？好吧，我知道。多年前，我们在 Earwolf 做过一个叫《大声朗读》的节目。
Can you put them in stories? Yeah, I absolutely will. But a lot of people are dressed up as different office characters. One of the gals that helped work my booth, Betty Jean, she's the sweetest. She told me that she first attended a convention doing cosplay of Pam. Sam, you've done cosplay at conventions, and while I'm slightly afraid to ask this question, would you like to share some of the characters you've dressed up as? I know Big Titty Gandalf is one.
那是一个由内特·科德里主持的朗读播客。亨利·温克勒是嘉宾。他打电话进来，结果工作室停电了，火警警报响了。显然，当大楼里的火警警报响起时，所有电力相关的东西都会关闭。所以控制台关闭了，于是我们失去了他。我们断了电话。我有一段超棒的语音留言。上面说：嗨，我是亨利·温克勒，演员。
Is that the official name of that one? Yes, Big Titty Gandalf is the name of the character. My personal favorites are I went as Ash from Evil Dead when I met Bruce Campbell. I just met Tim Curry last weekend dressed as Georgie from It with the missing one arm and the bloody raincoat. Other than that, I think those are my favorite. Do you have any plans to go to a convention? Do you have another one coming up?
我曾扮演过方兹。他说：我刚刚还在电话里。就像，他把自己的履历全报了一遍。这样你就知道他是谁了。因为他是地球上最好、最、最谦逊的人。所以我打算尝试拼凑出一个弗莱迪·克鲁格混搭方兹的造型。哦，你必须让我们看看照片。
I do. I'm meeting Robert England, who was Freddie Kruger in January and the Fonds in the same day. So I'm going to try and go as the funds. You're going to meet Henry Winkler? Yeah, I'm going to go. Do you know he's the nicest person on the whole earth? Okay, I do. Years ago, we had a show at Earwolf called Reading Aloud.
绝对的，是的。这现在是你的挑战了。绝对的。好吧。你在看或者看过《巴瑞》吗？是的。对，对，对。他在里面演得太棒了。
It was a reading podcast that Nate Cordry hosted. And Henry Rinkler was the guest. He called in, and the studio shut down, there was a fire alarm that went off. And apparently, when the fire alarm goes off in the building, everything shuts down electricity-wise. So the board shut down, so we lost him. We lost the phone call. I have this great voicemail. It goes, hi, it's Henry Winkler, the actor.
他是最棒的。他在那部剧以及《发展受阻》里都是最棒的。我爱他在《发展受阻》里的表演。好吧。谢谢你，萨姆。谢谢你，萨姆。哦，女士，说到角色扮演，我有没有给你发那个来我的剧院看戏、打扮成帕姆的姑娘的照片？
I was the Fonz. He goes, I was just on the call. Like, he gave his whole resume. So you knew who it was. Because he's the nicest, most, like, just humble person on earth. So I'm going to try and put together a Fred. Kruger slash Fawn's outfit. Oh, you have to show us a picture.
她打扮成帕姆，名字叫凯莉。我走到外面去进行舞台门口的互动，然后她就在那儿，她穿着一件纽扣衬衫、铅笔裙、运动鞋。太惊人了。我和她拍了张照。我会把它发给你放到动态里。我太喜欢了，珍娜。你知道，卡西有一个很棒的故事，有个粉丝跟她讲述了偶遇一位《办公室》演员的经历。卡西，你能分享一下吗？哦，天哪。这太独特了，我有一个片段，让我们听听看。我是索菲亚。我来自纽约。我是苏珊。我是她妈妈。我来自纽约州纽堡。是的。太棒了。这是你第一次参加办公室粉丝见面会吗？其实这是我们的第二次
Exactly, yeah. This is your challenge now. Exactly. Okay. Are you watching or have you watch Barry? Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's so good in it.
我们参加了第一届。所以，是的。你有像最喜欢的瞬间吗？来自你上次来粉丝见面会的时候我遇到了克里夫，有趣的是，我前一天刚拔了智齿。所以感觉就像我当时吃了止痛药
He's the best. He's the best in that and Arrested Development, too. I love him and Arrested Development. All right. Well, thanks, Sam. Thank you, Sam. Oh, lady, speaking of cosplay, did I send you the photo of the gal who came to my play dressed as Pam?
然后我就觉得这太棒了。这是度过这段时间的绝佳方式。但她又一次硬着头皮撑过来了。所以绝对是见到克里夫，这太棒了。是的，是的。你能想象在吃止痛药的情况下见到克里夫吗？不能。不能。你连百分之百清醒时克里夫说的任何话都很难完全相信。我知道。这太惊人了。卡西，粉丝见面会上有什么让你感到惊讶的事吗？是的，有两件事真的很触动我。第一件事是，我惊讶于有这么多家庭一起参加办公室粉丝见面会。真的太甜了。是的，有太多家庭了。我是说，有妈妈、爸爸、小孩子、青少年，看到他们所有人都在那儿真的感觉好温馨。安吉拉，你的家人当时也在粉丝见面会上吗？
As Pam, her name was Kelly. I walk out to do the stage door, and there. she is, she was in like a button-down blouse, a pencil skirt, sneakers. It was amazing. I took a photo with her. I will give it to you for stories. I love that, Jenna. You know, Cassie has a great story where a fan told her about meeting an office cast member. Cassie, can you share it? Oh my gosh. It's so unique, and I have a clip, so let's listen to it. I'm Sophia. I'm from New York. I'm Susan. I'm her mom. I'm from Newburgh, New York. Yeah. Love it. Is this your first office convention? This is our second actually
他们去了。所以乔希和孩子们顺道过来了。我们把这安排成了一次去纽约的家庭旅行，然后我们去了冰岛。是的。但他们确实待了半天，而且他们观看了问答环节。他们对这一切有什么看法？太疯狂了。我觉得人们，首先，当他们看到他们走进来时，人们鼓掌了，他们会说：“哦，很高兴你们能来，你知道的。”所以我觉得他们真正感受到了《办公室》粉丝群体对演员和剧组人员的温暖与喜爱。我觉得这对他们来说真的很特别。我觉得这也是那种“哦，那只是我妈妈。怎么回事？”的感觉。是的，你知道的，我的孩子们，他们不经常见到那种粉丝互动。所以我觉得他们有点像“哇”，当那个舞台门口打开，人们为他们的妈妈欢呼时。是的。你知道吗？我知道。你可不是每天都能遇到这种事的。就像当你说：“好了，要吃晚饭了。谁下来帮我们摆桌子？”他们可不会这样：
We were at the inaugural So yeah Do you have like a favorite moment From last time you came to the convention I met Creed and it's funny I got my wisdom teeth out the day before So it was like I was like on pain meds And I was like this is awesome
哔——！完全是这样。好吧，卡西，我看到你和我有幸遇到的一些家庭聊过天。你能跟我们分享一下吗？哦，天哪。是的，有太多家庭了，我喜欢和他们所有人聊天。我只想分享几个。这里有一段来自马克斯、艾米丽、埃拉以及他们的父母、来自新罕布什尔州的艾米和迈克的音频片段。我叫马克斯，我来自新罕布什尔州萨默斯沃思。
This is a great way to spend But she muscled through it again in here So definitely meeting Creed it was awesome Yeah yeah Can you imagine meeting Creed on painkillers? No No. You can barely believe anything Creed says when you're 100% sober. I know. That's amazing. Cassie, was there anything about the convention that surprised you? Yeah, two things really stood out to me. The first is I was surprised by how many families attended the office convention together. It was so sweet. Yeah, there were so many families. I'm talking like moms, dads, little kids, teenage kids, and it was really sweet to see them all there. Angela, wasn't your family at the convention?
新罕布什尔州。你叫什么名字？埃米。埃米。我是埃拉。埃拉。你们是父母吗？是的。
They did. So Josh and the kids stopped by. We made this sort of a family trip to New York and then we went on to Iceland. Yeah. But they did come for half a day and they were there for the Q&A panel. What did they think of all of it? It was wild. I think people, first of all, when they saw them walk in, people like clapped and they were like, oh, it's so glad you're here, you know. And so I think they really felt the warmth and love of the office fandom for the cast and the crew. And I think it was really special for. for them. I think it was also kind of that thing where it's like, well, that's just my mom. What's going on? Yeah, you know, my kids, they don't see that kind of like fandom interaction very often. And so I think they were a little bit like, whoa, like when that stage door would open and people were cheering for their mom. Yeah. You know? I know. You don't get that every day. Like when you're like, all right, it's dinner. Who's coming down and helps us at the table? They're not like,
艾米。迈克。太棒了。我想，你们所有人都很喜欢《办公室》？是的。我是看着它长大的。是的。你们都有最喜欢的单集吗？
B'bib! Exactly. Well, Cassie, I saw you talk. talking to a few of the families that I got to meet. Can you share with us about that? Oh, my gosh. Yeah, there are so many families, and I love talking with all of them. I just want to share a couple. Here's a clip of Max, Emily, Ella, and their parents, Amy and Mike from New Hampshire. My name is Max, and I'm from Summer's Worth, New Hampshire.
我真的很喜欢德怀特通过消防演习差点烧毁大楼的那一集。我看到你身上有《办公室》的纹身。你是家里唯一一个有《办公室》纹身的人吗？是的。确实是的。你能向播客听众透露一下你的《办公室》纹身是什么吗？好的。所以我的一个小腿上有“监狱迈克”，
New Hampshire. What's your name? Emmy. Emmy. And I'm Ella. Ella. And are you the parents? Yeah.
另一个小腿上是打扮成吉姆的德怀特。哇，太惊人了。说到家庭，我有一个关于一位爸爸和他的女儿们收听“办公室女士”的故事要分享。我没能见到这位爸爸，但女儿们在舞台门口，她们太可爱了。她们跟我讲了这个温馨的故事，我问她们是否愿意再说一遍，以便我能录下来。这是她们说的话。好的，女士们，说出你们的名字。德兰妮
Amy. Mike. Great. And I take it, you all love the office? Yes. I've been raised on it. Yeah. Do you all have like a favorite episode?
布里奇特。你们现在必须把刚刚告诉我、因为是全世界最可爱的事情讲给“办公室女士”的听众和安吉拉听。
I really like the one where Dwight almost burns down the building with a fire drill. I saw you have office tattoos. Are you the only one in the family with office tattoos? Yes. Sure is. Can you let the podcast know what your office tattoos are? Yep. So I've got one prison mic.
我和我爸爸每当在车里一起时都会听“办公室女士”播客。他叫布拉德，他和我的其余家人、卡特还有我妈妈
On one calf, and on the other calf is Dwight as Jim. Wow, that's amazing. You know, speaking of families, I have a share about a dad and his daughters who listened to office ladies. So I didn't get to meet the dad, but the daughters were at the stage door, and they were so sweet. They told me the sweet story, and I asked if they would say it again, if I could record it. Here's what they said. Okay, ladies, say your name. Delaney
斯黛西是最大的粉丝。它在我们家里一直单曲循环。我爱你们。你们必须说。你们为什么今晚来到芝加哥看这场演出？
Bridget You have to now tell the Office Ladies listeners and Angela what you just told me because it's the cutest thing in the whole world
我们来这里是因为你给我们买票来看演出，而且太棒了。你爸爸给你买票，然后说：“女士们，去看这场演出吧。”谢谢。你爸爸叫什么名字？布拉德。布拉德，谢谢你。是不是超级甜？她说她爸爸在播客里听说了这部剧，然后他说：
My dad and I listen to the Office Ladies podcast whenever we're in the car together His name is Brad and he and the rest of my family Carter and my mom
“女孩们，你们得去看看，”并给她们买了票。太甜蜜了。这就是凯蒂和克里斯。没错。太，我太喜欢了。我喜欢这部剧以及播客将各个家庭凝聚在一起。卡西，还有吗？是的，我再分享一个。
Stacy were the biggest fan It's on repeat in our house all the time I love you And you have to say Why are you here tonight in Chicago seeing this play
我很喜欢和这个家庭聊天，来自南卡罗来纳州和佐治亚州的爱丽丝、布里奇特和安德森。我是爱丽丝·斯卡伯勒，我来自南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿。布里奇特·斯卡伯勒，佐治亚州萨凡纳。安德森·斯卡伯勒，佐治亚州萨凡纳。太棒了。你们穿的是什么？我是一只熊。我是一根甜菜。
We're here because you bought us tickets to come and see it, and it was amazing. Your dad bought you tickets and was like, ladies, go see this show. Thank you. What's your dad's name? Brad. Brad, thank you. Isn't that so sweet? She said her dad heard about the play on the podcast, and he said,
我是《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》。太棒了，太棒了。这是你们第一次参加办公室粉丝见面会吗？是的。《办公室》对你们意味着什么？一切。嗯哼。我想我几乎每天都在看。
Girls, you got to go see it, and he got them tickets. That is so sweet. This is Katie and Chris. Exactly. It's so, I just love it. I love the show bringing families together and the podcast. Cassie, any more? Yeah, I'll share one more.
这就好像是我伴着入睡的东西，我知道如果我播放《办公室》，那就是该睡觉的时间了。它给我们带来了太多的快乐。我们喜欢大家聚在一起时看它。我们今天早上准备出门时就在看。它真的……它给我们带来了……是的，很熟悉。我不会撒谎。
I really enjoyed talking to this family, Elise, Bridget, and Anderson from South Carolina and Georgia. I am Elise Scarborough, and I'm from Charleston, South Carolina. Bridget Scarborough, Savannah, Georgia. Anderson Scarborough, Savannah, Georgia. Love it. And what are you wearing? I am a bear. I am a beat.
我曾经很长一段时间都不喜欢《办公室》。我一开始并不喜欢它。因为他们两个，尤其是爱丽丝，她总是会在做饭时在车里播放它。它总是在播放。然后我会说：“喂，大家，这根本没那么好笑。”然后我想，大概吧，我看了有一两集。然后我就觉得，天哪，这其实真的很好笑。我把整季都看完了。
and I am Battlestar Galactica. Love it, love it. Is this your first office convention? Yes. And what does the office mean to you? Everything. Uh-huh. I think I watch it every single day.
而我是《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》。太棒了，太棒了。这是你们第一次参加《办公室》粉丝见面会吗？是的。《办公室》对你们意味着什么？全部。嗯哼。我想我几乎每天都在看。
It's like what I fall asleep to, I know if I put the office on, it's time for bed. It just brings us so much joy. We like to watch it when we all hang out together. We're watching it this morning getting ready. It's just really... It gives us... Yeah, it's familiar. I'm not going to lie.
这就像是我入睡时的伴音，我知道只要放起《办公室》，就该睡觉了。它给我们带来了无限的欢乐。我们聚在一起时喜欢看它。今天早上我们准备出门时也在看。它真的……它给我们一种……对，很熟悉的感觉。说实话。
I did not like the office for the longest time. I did not like it. Because them two, especially at least, she would always throw it on in the car during making dinner. It was always on. And I'd be like, y'all, it's not even that funny. And then I think, like, I don't know, I caught like an episode or two. And I was like, dang, this is actually really funny. I watched through the whole season.
我好长时间都不喜欢《办公室》。我一开始真的很不喜欢。因为他们两个，尤其是她，做饭时总喜欢在车里放这个。总是在放。然后我就想，天哪，这根本没那么好笑。后来我觉得，不知怎么的，我看了那么一两集。然后我就想，天哪，这其实真的很好笑。我把整季都看完了。
And I remember sitting in my mom's house watching the finale at like three in the morning because I just had to finish it that night. And when Steve Carell came back, and I cried, I bawled my eyes out, dog. I cried so bad. It was such an amazing finale. And I always say that if aliens would have ever come down and they were like, yo, give us a TV show to watch it, describe America. I think the office would be like the perfect thing. Like, that's the show that would describe America as a whole.
我还记得大约凌晨三点在我妈妈家看大结局，因为我必须当晚看完。当史蒂夫·卡瑞尔回来的时候，我哭了，我哭得稀里哗啦的，兄弟。我哭得好伤心。这是一个太棒的大结局了。我总是说，如果外星人降临地球，对我们说，哟，给我们一个电视剧看，用来描述美国。我觉得《办公室》会是完美的选择。就像，那是能全面描述美国的剧集。
Get them called it dispedia. Yeah. Can I tell you what I love about Anderson? Anderson went from turn off that show, get it out of my life, to being dressed as Battlestar Galactica in a three-person outfit at an office convention. Right. That is a journey that he has gone on. Also, to say, okay, aliens, this is what our gift to you, now you understand our world. That was awesome.
有人管它叫“办公室百科”。是的。我能告诉你我最喜欢安德森的什么吗？安德森从“关掉那个节目，把它从我的生活中拿开”，变成了在一个办公室粉丝见面会上穿着《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》三人套装的人。没错。那是他经历过的一段旅程。而且，还要说，好吧，外星人们，这是我们送给你们的礼物，现在你们理解我们的世界了。那太棒了。
Cassie, you said there was one other thing that really surprised you. What was it? Yeah. I kept asking fans what their favorite office episode was. was, and so many fans kept saying this one episode, and I wouldn't have ever guessed it. Do you guys want to try to guess? Okay, so it's something I wouldn't guess because my first instinct would be like dinner party or booze cruise or something.
卡西，你说还有一件事真的很让你惊讶。是什么？是的。我一直在问粉丝们他们最喜欢《办公室》的哪一集，许多粉丝都一直提到这一集，而我怎么也猜不到。你们想猜猜看吗？好吧，所以这是一件我猜不到的事，因为我的第一直觉会是像“公司派对”或者“酒水游轮”之类的。
So this is one I wouldn't guess. Oh, I'm thinking. I'm thinking, too. Goodbye, Michael is my guess. I'll go season one and I'll say Diversity Day. Oh, no. Max actually hinted at it. It's stress relief.
所以这是我猜不到的一集。哦，我在想。我也在想。《再见，迈克尔》是我的猜测。我选第一季，我猜是《多元化日》。哦，不。马克斯其实给过提示。是《压力缓解》。
Stress relief. People love stress relief. Because of that cold open? Yeah. Yeah, with the fire, safe bandit. We should watch the superfan version of stress relief. Sure. Yeah.
《压力缓解》。人们太爱《压力缓解》了。因为那个冷场白？对。是的，有火灾那个，安全带。我们应该看《压力缓解》的超级粉丝版。当然。是的。
Maybe we should if it's everybody's favorite. I know. I wonder what new little nuggets are in that one. I wonder. We might have to hit up David Rogers. I've noticed you've started calling Dave Rogers David Rogers. Is this his preferred name now? No, I think it's because I have a brother-in-law named David,
也许我们应该看，如果这是每个人最喜欢的话。我知道。我想知道那一集里有什么新的小爆料。我也想知道。我们可能得联系一下大卫·罗杰斯。我注意到你开始叫戴夫·罗杰斯为大卫·罗杰斯了。这是他现在更喜欢的名字吗？不，我想是因为我有一个叫大卫的姐夫，
who I called Dave constantly, and then sort of heard my sister-in-law and some of his family always say David. And then I said to Josh, is he Dave or David? And then he was like, he's Dave. I'm like, okay, fine. And then his sister was like, no, he's David. Oh. But is Dave Rogers now, David?
我经常叫他戴夫，然后听到我嫂子和他家里的某个人总是叫大卫。然后我问乔希，他是叫戴夫还是大卫？然后他说，他叫戴夫。我说，好吧，行。然后他姐姐说，不，他是大卫。哦。但戴夫·罗杰斯现在是大卫吗？
I don't know. And I think I have this default now where I'm like, I'm going to say both. I'm going to do 50-50. Sometimes I'm going to say Dave. Sometimes I'm going to say David. I was just checking. I'm covering all my bases. Well, the next time we have lunch with him, maybe we should ask.
我不知道。我想我现在有了这种默认习惯，我想：我要两个都叫。我搞个五五开。有时我叫戴夫。有时我叫大卫。我只是确认一下。我两边都照顾到了。好吧，下次我们和他吃午饭时，也许我们应该问问。
Okay. Well, Angela, you mentioned that you met people from all over the world. I'm curious, who traveled the furthest? Do we know to the convention? I remember who I talked to, and I can let Adam answer. Oh. Oh, okay. Okay.
好吧。好吧，安吉拉，你提到你遇到了来自世界各地的人。我很好奇，谁走得最远？我们知道是谁去参加见面会的吗？我记得我和谁聊过，我可以让亚当来回答。哦。哦，好吧。好吧。
Adam from England. Yeah. Oh, did you travel all the way to be here today? Yeah, just for this. Oh my gosh. I've seen pictures of the past ones and I thought, oh, I've got, I wish I could go. And then this is the last one, so yeah, I had to do it. Yeah, it's amazing.
来自英国的亚当。哦，你是一路长途跋涉来到这里参加今天的活动的吗？是的，特地为这个来的。哦天哪。我见过过去活动的图片，我想，哦，我希望，我真希望我也能去。然后这是最后一次了，所以，是的，我必须来。是的，这太棒了。
Yeah. Awesome. Yeah. Now you said you listen to the podcast. Do you have like a favorite episode or a moment from the podcast? I really enjoyed one of the latest ones with Lucy Davis, obviously, because of the sort of British connection as well. Yeah. That was fascinating. Yeah, really good. Yeah. Okay, I remember Adam. So I met Adam and we were talking about the podcast and he said one of the things, you know, that was always hard for him is if we had to skip a week, if we were going in order and we had to skip a week because it was like Christmas break or whatever.
太棒了。是的。现在你说你听这个播客。你有没有最喜欢的播客单集或者某个时刻？我真的很喜欢最近和露西·戴维斯的其中一期，显然是因为某种英国的渊源。是的。那太迷人了。是的，真的很好。是的。好吧，我记得亚当。所以我遇到了亚当，我们在聊播客，他说有一件事，你知道的，对他来说一直很难，那就是如果我们漏了一周没更新，如果我们是按顺序播出的，而我们因为圣诞假期或其他原因不得不跳过一周的话。
Oh, and we left him hanging. Yeah. It was like a two-part episode. Yes, especially if it was a two-part episode. And I told him, I was like, you're going to love Monday second drinks because it's, is the entire show, the whole rewatch in order. We're not going to miss one. And we're adding new information at the top. Anything we missed. So you're going to get a little more stuff at the top. But I was like, don't you worry, Adam. It's going to be in order. I'm glad you mentioned the second drinks because I had a couple people ask me what they were. Like they were confused by it. And it's been going on for almost two years now. And I guess for anyone who missed it, it's our original rewatch, but with about 10 minutes of new information at the top. So you can just listen to the 10 minutes if you want, or if you want to listen to that and then keep going, you can
哦，我们把他晾在那儿了。是的。就像一个两集连播的剧集。是的，特别是如果它是一个两集连播的剧集。我告诉他，我说：你会爱死周一的“续杯时光”（second drinks）的，因为它就是整个节目，整个按顺序重温的过程。我们不会漏掉任何一期。而且我们在开头添加了新信息。我们错过的任何东西。所以你会在开头得到更多一点的内容。但我说：别担心，亚当。它会按顺序播出的。我很高兴你提到“续杯时光”，因为有几个人问我那是什么。好像他们对此感到困惑。而且这已经持续了快两年了。我想对于任何错过它的人来说，这是我们最初的重温节目，但在开头增加了大约10分钟的新信息。所以如果你愿意，你只听那10分钟就行了，或者如果你想听完那部分然后继续听下去，你可以
revisit all of our Office Ladies episodes in order with no breaks, like you said. Yeah, especially because when we first started the rewatch, there was a lot of information that we gathered as we went. We found more scripts. We found the candy bag alts. We found outlines. We had writers assistants, writers, directors, give us a whole bunch of information. So if we missed anything, now is our chance with the second drinks to include all that. I'm also going back to our archive fan mailbags for all of those episodes, and I'm pulling extra questions or things that people are telling us we missed or got wrong. So if you wrote us like five years ago, you might hear yourself on a second drink.
按顺序重温我们所有的《办公室女士》剧集，没有中断，就像你说的。是的，尤其是因为当我们刚开始重温时，我们在进行过程中收集了大量信息。我们找到了更多的剧本。我们找到了糖果袋的替代台词。我们找到了大纲。我们有编剧助理、编剧、导演给我们提供了一大堆信息。所以如果我们错过了什么，现在在“续杯时光”中就是我们把这些全部包含进来的机会。我也在为所有这些剧集翻找我们的资料库粉丝信箱，我正在挑选额外的问题，或者人们告诉我们我们遗漏了或弄错了的事情。所以如果你在五年前给我们写过信，你可能会在“续杯时光”里听到你自己的声音。
Yeah. To the guy that wrote me that we missed a Daryl storyline, you're going to hear it. Well, I had a lot of people share that they traveled to see the play. It just warmed my heart. I would go out to the stage door and people would literally have their luggage with them. Like they came right off the train or, you know, right from the airport. Someone told me they traveled solo from Singapore. Wow.
是的。对于那个写信说我们漏掉了一条达里尔故事线的伙计，你会听到的。嗯，有很多人分享说他们长途跋涉来看这部剧。这真的温暖了我的心。我会走到舞台门口，人们真的随身带着行李。就像他们刚下火车，或者，你知道的，刚从机场出来一样。有人告诉我他们独自从新加坡旅行过来。哇。
There was someone from Brazil, someone from Argentina. And then just lots of people from all around the country. And that was really moving to me that people came out to support the play. And my favorite was when there was like a group of people who had all traveled together or met up. I know a lot of people coordinated that on our Facebook fan page. I just loved seeing how office ladies brought people together. And then they went on these creative adventures. Yeah. You know, like going to the convention together, coming to see the play. And there was one group. They called themselves, oh my gosh, what were they called? Oh, they called themselves
有人来自巴西，有人来自阿根廷。然后还有来自全国各地的大量人。这对我真的很触动，人们出来支持这部剧。我最喜欢的是有一群人，他们都是一起旅行的或者是在那里碰面的。我知道很多人在我们的Facebook粉丝主页上协调这件事。我只是喜欢看到《办公室女士》是如何把人们凝聚在一起的。然后他们去进行这些充满创意的冒险。是的。你知道的，比如一起去参加见面会，来看这部剧。还有一个群体。他们自称，哦天哪，他们叫什么来着？哦，他们自称
the culture club. It was like their version of a finer things club. And they go out and they go see art or plays. And so thank you to the culture club for coming to see Ashland Avenue. It is really, you know, special, though, the Office Ladies' Facebook fan page that is moderated by Nikki and all of these wonderful people that have met. Oh, Nikki came to Ashland Avenue. Yeah, I saw your picture. Yes. Yeah. And, you know, it is a really wonderful community. And a lot of people have made friendships and I think lasting friendships through this group. And Cassie, you said you talked to some office ladies folks, too. Yeah. Oh, my goodness. I met so many Office Ladies fans. I really want to share this clip from Richard and Rachel from South Carolina.
文化俱乐部。这就像是他们的精美事物俱乐部的版本。他们出去看艺术展或戏剧。所以感谢文化俱乐部来看《阿什兰大道》。说实话，你知道的，《办公室女士》的Facebook粉丝主页真的很特别，它由妮琪和所有这些建立起联系的优秀的人们进行版主管理。哦，妮琪来了《阿什兰大道》。对，我看到你的照片了。是的。是的，而且，你知道的，这真的是一个很棒的社区。很多人通过这个群体结下了友谊，而且我认为是持久的友谊。卡西，你说你也和一些《办公室女士》的粉丝聊过。是的。哦，天哪。我遇到了太多的《办公室女士》粉丝了。我真的很想分享这段来自南卡罗来纳州的理查德和蕾切尔的剪辑。
You have to hear where Rachel listens to Office Ladies. Okay. I'm Richard and this is Rachel. We're from South Carolina. Awesome. And what are you wearing? So we're wearing our Michael Scott, Stunder Mithlin, Scranton, Meredith, Homer, Memorial, Celebrity, Rabies, Awareness, Pro-Am, run for, fun run, raise for the cure. It's hard to read upside down. They hung up. No, Michael came over that name. They need to hear the entire name. What does the office mean to you? Some of the last good television, I think.
你们必须听听蕾切尔是在哪里听《办公室女士》的。好吧。我是理查德，这是蕾切尔。我们来自南卡罗来纳州。太棒了。你们穿着什么？所以我们穿着我们的迈克尔·斯科特·邓德米夫林·斯克兰顿·梅雷迪思·帕尔默纪念名人狂犬病意识职业业余配对慈善趣味赛跑，为治愈而筹款T恤。倒着看太难读了。他们挂断了。不，迈克尔想出了那个名字。他们需要听到完整的名字。《办公室》对你们意味着什么？一些最后的优秀的电视节目，我觉得。
I mean, it's just, it's excellent television, and it's a way that we unwind, like, every day, and it's our time to just relax. Yeah, after a really stressful day, we've got kids, we've got a farm, we've got our jobs. It's nice to just get together today, snuggle up in bed, the office. It helps put us to sleep every night. It's such great riding. It's so, it's just so
我的意思是，这简直是极好的电视节目，这是我们每天放松的一种方式，这是我们只是放松的时刻。是的，在经历了一个非常压力山大的日子之后，我们有孩子，我们有农场，我们有工作。很高兴今天能聚在一起，依偎在床上，《办公室》。它帮助我们每天晚上入睡。它的剧作太棒了。它是那么，它简直是太
good. Half of our goats are named after the office characters. Oh my gosh. We breed goats and one of our bucks is named Michael Scott. And so we have a lot of Scott's tauts. When you said farm, I was just like, oh, they're referring to their kids, but no, you have a literal farm with goats. That's so cool. I'm usually listening to office ladies when I'm bush hogging the fields. Like, that is how I drown out the tractor noise is I listen to office ladies and look at my goats named after the office characters. Rachel, I love it.
好了。我们有一半的山羊都是以《办公室》的角色命名的。哦天哪。我们饲养山羊，我们的其中一只公羊名叫迈克尔·斯科特。所以我们有很多斯科特的烤薯饼（Scott's Tots）。当你提到农场时，我当时就想，哦，他们指的是他们的孩子，但不是，你们有一个真正的养山羊的农场。这太酷了。我通常是在清理田地里的灌木丛时听《办公室女士》的。就像，我就是用这种方式来掩盖拖拉机噪音的，那就是听《办公室女士》，看着我那些以《办公室》角色命名的山羊。蕾切尔，我太喜欢了。
I hope right now that's happening. I hope we're in your ear right now. I know, Rachel, I keep telling Josh, I want one of those little mini goats. Oh, you want one of Scott's tots. I do. I said that on the Today Show when we were on for our cookbook.
我希望现在正发生着这件事。我希望我们现在就在你的耳边。我知道，蕾切尔，我一直告诉乔希，我想要那些迷你小山羊中的一只。哦，你想要一只斯科特的烤薯饼。我确实想要。我们在上《今日秀》宣传我们的食谱时我就这么说过。
At the end, they were like, oh, Angela, do you have like cats in real life? And I was like, we have cats, we have dogs. I was like, I'd have more animals. if Josh would let me, like, I want a goat. And you could have heard record scratch. And someone goes, a goat? How delightful? Something like that.
最后，他们问，哦，安吉拉，你在现实生活中养猫吗？我说，我们有猫，我们有狗。我说，只要乔希允许，我会养更多动物，比如，我想要一只山羊。然后你可以听到唱片划针刮擦的声音。然后有人说：一只山羊？多么令人愉快啊？诸如此类的话。
And I was like, oh, no, that'll be the thing that haunts me. And sure enough, my family was like, you won't goats. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're just going to keep chatting about our convention and stage door adventures. This Cyber Monday, discover the smart way to scent your home with Pura. Enjoy 30% off curated sets, including the sleek Pura 4 and Pura Plus diffusers. Fill your space with premium fragrance, control your scent from anywhere,
然后我就想，哦，不，这会成为纠缠我的事情。果不其然，我的家人说：你想要山羊。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？当我们回来时，我们将继续聊聊我们的见面会和舞台门冒险。在这个网络星期一，发现用Pura为您的家增添香气的明智方式。享受精选套装30%的折扣，包括时尚的Pura 4和Pura Plus扩香器。用优质香水充满您的空间，随时随地控制您的气味，
and set custom schedules for every mood. It's the easiest way to upgrade your home for less. Don't miss your chance to save 30% only at Pura.com for a limited time. All right, we're back. And I don't know why I didn't mention this earlier, but there was a huge group of people one night at the stage door. They called themselves the convention people. They were like, we're the convention people. They had all been at the convention together, and then they all came out to Chicago. And lady, that is the group that was holding your cookbook in the reel that I posted
并为每种心情设置自定义日程。这是以更低价格升级您家的最简单方法。不要错过仅在 Pura.com 限时享受 30% 折扣的机会。好了，我们回来了。我不知道为什么我早些时候没提到这个，但有一天晚上在舞台门口有一大群人。他们自称是“见面会的人”。他们就像是：我们是见面会的人。他们当时都在见面会现场，然后他们都来到了芝加哥。女士，那就是在10月份为了你的书发布会而我在Instagram上发布的那个短视频中，
on Instagram back in October for your book launch. Oh, that was so sweet. They were so sweet. I had your cookbook in my backpack because I was flipping. through the recipes at intermission. And I was like, oh, this is the perfect crowd. And one of the things they told me, they were so sweet. They were like, Jackie DeBotton says hi. Jim McDermott says hi. Because Jim McDermott was at the convention. Yes. He was our set dresser on the office. Yes. So, you know, in the years past, several of our crew members have been able to attend the convention and share their experience. And it was so great to see Jim. I was able to chat with him one morning. And Cassie, you got to talk to him too, right? Yeah. So when I wasn't in Angela's line,
拿着你的食谱的那个群体。哦，那太甜了。他们太可爱了。我的背包里装着你的食谱，因为我在中场休息时翻看食谱。然后我想，哦，这是完美的人群。他们告诉我的一件事，他们太可爱了。他们说：杰基·德博顿向你问好。吉姆·麦克德莫特向你问好。因为吉姆·麦克德莫特去了见面会。是的。他是我们在《办公室》的布景道具师。是的。所以，你知道的，在过去的几年里，我们的几位剧组成员都能够参加见面会并分享他们的经验。很高兴见到吉姆。有一天早上我得以和他聊天。卡西，你也和他聊过，对吧？是的。所以当我不排安吉拉的队时，
I went around and I talked to different cast members and I talked to Jim as well. So here's a great clip of him describing his job and some of the challenges he had working on the show. Do you want to describe your job for the fans? Me, to set that career, go to production. We get the script early, read it, break it down, determine how much manpower we need, truck power, how much the rentals would be for each set and how much purchases we'd have to budget that in and we always came within a thousand dollars so we did a pretty good job and there were some pretty big sets and everybody thought yeah you got the easiest job in town all you got into the office it's like no we got the new york
我四处走动，和不同的演员聊天，我也和吉姆聊了。所以这里有一段他描述自己的工作以及他在剧中工作时遇到的一些挑战的精彩剪辑。你想为粉丝们描述一下你的工作吗？我，作为布景道具师，去到制片厂。我们很早就拿到剧本，阅读它，将其拆解，确定我们需要多少人力、卡车运力，每个布景的租赁费用是多少，以及我们需要为此做多少预算，而我们总是能将预算控制在千元以内，所以我们干得相当不错。而且有一些相当大的布景，每个人都认为，是的，你得到了城里最轻松的工作，你所要做的就是进入办公室。就像，不，我们有纽约办公室，我们有奥斯卡的公寓，我们有吉姆的公寓，但我们拥有一切，你知道的，仓库布景非常巨大，然后我们还有所有其他地区办公室，纳舒厄和所有其他办公室，所以我的意思是，你知道的，我们进入空旷的办公楼，重新搭建这些布景，制作各种图形和一切，你知道的，邓德米夫林图形，这真是一件有趣的事情。你有没有，比如说，你创作的最喜欢的布景？嗯，这个就在珍娜的桌子后面。嗨，珍娜。我给你看。就是这个。这是一张带有詹姆斯名字的参与证书。哦，对，就在后面。如果你听到这种尖叫声，那是一场吃饼干比赛。莱斯利·大卫·贝克刚上台。
office we had we had oscars apart we had games apart but we had everything you know the warehouse set was huge and then we had all the other district offices Nashua and all these other ones so i mean you know we went into empty office buildings recreated those and made all kinds of graphics and everything, you know, the Dundra Mifty graphics, and it was just such a fun thing to do. Do you have, like, a favorite set that you created? Well, this was behind Jenna's desk. Hi, Jenna. I'll show you. It was this right here. This is a certificate of participation with James' name on it. Oh, yeah, it's right behind. If you hear this screaming, it's a pretzel eating contest. Leslie David Baker just got on stage.
这太棒了。你有没有哪一集《办公室》让你觉得：这一集工作起来简直是我的眼中钉？我觉得纽约的公司总部办公室，当我们第一次做的时候，有点棘手，但它主要是一条走廊和几个房间，还有一个大厅。其实没那么糟。我们在吉姆的公寓里投入了很多细节，那是一个非常好的布景。是的，那是一个不错的布景。那是德怀特抱起那个婴儿，它在现实生活中停止哭泣的时候。婴儿停止哭泣了。
It's great. Do you have an office episode that you're like, this one was a pain in my butt to work on? I think the New York corporate office when we first did it, it was kind of tricky, but it was mostly hallway in a couple, and a lobby. It wasn't so bad. We put a lot of detail into Gabe's apartment, and that was a really nice set. Yeah, that was a good one. That's when Dwight picked up the baby and it stopped crying in real life. The baby stopped crying.
那真是一条过（one take）搞定，伙计。是的。然后那是一个非常好的布景。在奥斯卡家，我们在奥斯卡的公寓里投入了很多心思。我们在那里实际上有一个浴室，我们做得很好，但他们从未在浴室里拍摄过。哦，不。是的。
It was a good one take, man. Yeah. And then that was a real nice set. And Oscars, we put a lot of thought in the Oscars apartment. We actually had a bathroom in there that we did a nice job, but they never shot in the bathroom. Oh, no. Yeah.
但他们对我们真的很好。我的意思是，每个人合作起来都很酷。所有的演员都非常好。太棒了。最后一个问题。所以你们进去并在他们实际拍摄时搭建布景。你在拍摄期间留在布景现场吗？他被称为现场道具师。
But they were really good people to us. I mean, everybody was cool to work with. All the actors were really nice. That's great. Last question. So you go in and you create the set when they're actually shooting. Do you stay on set during the shoot? He's called an on-set dresser.
他跟着摄像机。但我们早上进去，去得更早，小伙子们打扫所有的布景，他们吸尘、除尘并清理所有东西，但你知道的，我们会把斯坦利所有的填字游戏留在他的桌子上，并确保克里德有他的纸牌游戏摆好，我有一个每周进来清理电脑的家伙，一个IT人员，呃，我们在里面有活的植物，所以没有什么假的，所以我拿到了采购波西纸的订单，他们每个月给我们免费的剧本纸，所以可能仅在纸张上就为他们节省了数百万美元，然后我们会把空箱子放在仓库布景的托盘上。
He stays with the camera. But we come in in the morning, there earlier and the guys clean all the sets they vacuum and dust and clean up everything but you know we'll leave all stanley's crossword puzzles on his desk and make sure creed has this solitary game up and i have a guy that comes in and cleans the computers every week an IT guy and uh we had live plants in there so there's nothing fake so i got the order for the uh boisey paper and they gave us free script paper every month so probably saved them millions of dollars on paper alone and then we would take the empty boxes and put them in the warehouse set on pallets.
哦，是的。所以仓库布景里的所有箱子都是空的。哇。是的。当他们必须搬运某些东西并装载时，我们在里面放了小沙袋。哦。装满了沙子。所以当他们放下它时。
Oh, yeah. So all those boxes in the warehouse set were empty. Whoa. Yeah. When they had to go through something and load up, we put little sandbags in them. Oh. Full of sand. So they dropped it.
听起来很重。好吧。然后是道具，我们拿到的所有道具，就像，还记得德怀特摊位旁边的青蛙贴纸吗？我把它贴在那上面的。哦。所以我们联系了。我们一直在想办法如何使用来自斯克兰顿的东西。
It sounded like it was heavy. Okay. And then the props, all the props we got, like, remember the froggy sticker next to Dwight's stand? I put that on there. Oh. So we had, we got in touch. We were trying to figure out how to use things from Scranton.
听起来挺重的。好吧。然后是道具，我们拿到的所有道具，比如，还记得德怀特展位旁边的那只青蛙贴纸吗？那是我贴上去的。哦。所以我们联系上了。我们当时在想办法怎么用上来自斯克兰顿的东西。
So I suggested we call Mari Pottis is her name. She's the Chamber of Commerce President. And we're like, can we get some local Scranton goods from your local businesses? Yeah. But they got to sign off. We thought we'd get like three or four boxes. We got ten pallets of stuff.
所以我建议我们联系一下，玛丽·波蒂斯是她的名字。她是商会会长。我们就在想，能从你们当地企业买到一些斯克兰顿的特色商品吗？可以。但他们得签字同意。我们本以为能拿三四个盒子。结果我们收到了十托盘的东西。
Oh, my God. Yeah. Tons of stuff. Yeah. That's amazing. Yeah. So we got to, we used a lot of it. You know, refrigerator had all kinds of menus on it.
哦，天哪。对。超多东西。对。太棒了。对。所以我们不得不，我们用了很大一部分。你知道，冰箱上有各种各样的菜单。
Alferado's pizzas are real pizzeria. Yeah. Yeah. So I got, I ended up meeting a lot of people that are friends with in Scranton. So I'm going to go to the 5K next year. Yeah. I want to go. I wish Jenna was here.
阿尔弗雷多披萨是一家真正的披萨店。对。对。所以我最后结识了许多在斯克兰顿的朋友。所以我明年要去参加5公里长跑。对。我想去。我希望珍娜也在这儿。
I hope Jenna's doing okay. Hi, Jenna. Yeah, she's doing okay. She's working on a play in Chicago now. Oh, that's great. I love that detail that he shared about the pallets in the warehouse, that we got all that free paper that we used to print our scripts every week, and then they just filled them with sandbags.
希望珍娜一切都好。嗨，珍娜。对，她挺好的。她现在在芝加哥排练一句话剧。哦，太棒了。我很喜欢他分享的关于仓库里那些托盘的细节，我们拿到了所有那些免费的纸张，每周用来打印剧本，然后他们直接往里面塞满了沙袋。
I had no idea. All those boxes were empty. Yeah, I just assumed all those were actually filled with paper, I guess, because they were heavy. Well, I remember Oscar's apartment with such detail. I took a bunch of pictures of it because I was doing a home renovation. And I was like, you guys, this is so beautiful. And I didn't realize they didn't do a single scene in the bathroom.
我完全不知道。原来那些箱子都是空的。对，我一直以为那些里面真的装满了纸，因为它们挺重的。不过，我对奥斯卡的公寓印象非常深刻。我拍了好多照片，因为我当时正在做家居装修。然后我就想，天哪，这也太漂亮了。我当时居然没意识到他们在浴室里连一场戏都没拍过。
You know, they built a whole bathroom set for Ashland Avenue because our characters walk in there from time to time. But only like this tiny sliver of the audience could see it. It was literally like 12 seats could see into the bathroom. But they built a whole bathroom. I was really appreciative of it because otherwise I would have been like walking backstage and just kind of pretending I was in a bathroom, but I could stand in a real bathroom. That's cool. I did not see the bathroom set.
你知道的，他们为阿什兰大街搭建了整套浴室布景，因为我们的角色偶尔会走进去。但只有一小撮观众能看到。简直就像只有12个座位能看到浴室里面。但他们真的搭建了一个完整的浴室。我对此非常感激，因为否则我就会像是在后台走来走去，假装自己在浴室里，但我可以站在一个真正的浴室里。太酷了。我没看到那个浴室布景。
No, no, no, no, literally 12 people. Like our director, Susan Booth, she'd always be like, okay, Jenna, exit to the bathroom. 12 people will get to see what you're doing in there. So don't forget, you got to keep acting while you're in there. Wow. Yeah. That's so cool. Oh, and Jim gave me something to give to you to.
不，不，不，不，真的只有12个人。就像我们的导演苏珊·布思，她总是会说：“好了，珍娜，退场去浴室吧。有12个人能看到你在里面干什么了。”所以别忘了，你在里面的时候还得继续演戏。哇。对。太酷了。哦，吉姆给了我一样东西让我转交给你。
Oh, he did? What? Yeah. So he gave me the day. daily call sheet for the pilot. Oh, wow. Wow. And it's like the, oh my goodness. You know what? I have this as a digital thing. All right. Yeah, so this is the call sheet for, it says day 2.5 of 5.5. So day two of the pilot. Here's what it says under set dressing. It says that they're going to need a coat rack, a Homer Simpson doll, an office plant, and a Billy Bass Fisher. on the wall. I didn't realize the Billy Bass Fish went that far back. It does, I guess.
哦，是吗？什么？对。他给了我试播集的每日通告单。哦，哇。哇。这简直是，哦天哪。你知道吗？我这里有电子版的。好吧。对，所以这是通告单，上面写着：5.5天中的第2.5天。也就是试播集的第二天。场景布景这一栏里是这么写的：他们需要一个衣帽架、一个荷马·辛普森玩偶、一盆办公室绿植，以及一面墙上的山口巨鲈（Billy Bass）挂饰。我之前没意识到大口黑鲈鱼的梗历史这么悠久。看来是的。
All right. Well, listen, since we're giving gifts, I have stuff that people gave me at the stage door for all of you. Angela, I'm going to start with you. Jackie gifted us the cutest Chicago-inspired sweatshirts. She makes these on her Etsy shop. It's called Jacqueline Louise, please. She made you a Chicago deep dish pizza sweatshirt. Oh, deep dish pizza sounds really good right now. She made me a Chicago hot dog. I loved the Chicago hot dogs when I was there, so I'm very excited that she gave me the hot dog one. And in her note, she said, quote, I knew not to give you the deep dish one because nothing compares to emo's. So there you go, lady. Also, Stephanie C made us each keychains. So here's the story. She told you. She told you.
好吧，听着，既然我们在送礼物，我这里有大家在后台出口送给你们的礼物。安吉拉，我从你开始。杰基送给我们超可爱的芝加哥风卫衣。这是她在她的Etsy小店里制作的。店名叫“杰奎琳·路易斯，求你了”（Jacqueline Louise, Please）。她给你做了一件芝加哥深盘披萨卫衣。哦，深盘披萨现在听起来太诱人了。她给我做了一件芝加哥热狗卫衣。我在那儿的时候可喜欢芝加哥热狗了，所以我特别高兴她送了我热狗这件。她在便签里写道，引述一下：“我知道不能送你深盘披萨那件，因为没什么能比得上埃莫（Emo's）披萨。”所以就这样啦，女士。另外，斯蒂芬妮·C给我们每人都做了钥匙扣。事情是这样的。她跟你说过的。她跟你说过。
told me that she had sent some to us way back when we were at Earwolf. She asked me if we got them. She said it was around the time we were transitioning and she was worried they got lost in the move. So she was hand delivering new ones to us. Stephanie, I have to tell you something when I finally unwrapped these, we did get your first son of keychains. And now we all have two keychains from you. Yay. And we love them. Mine has a little engraved quote on it that says what one man can do, another can do. I love it. Mine says, lady, thanks for all the laughs. I hope to meet you in real life someday, so you will chat me up like we're old friends. Oh, I love it. That's so great. I also got some gifts from Ben and Sarah. They have a company called Just Be. That's B-E. And they gifted,
她告诉我，早在我们还在Earwolf的时候她就寄过一些给我们。她问我我们收到了没有。她说那正值我们转场期间，她担心东西在搬家时弄丢了。所以她要亲手把新的送给我们。斯蒂芬妮，我拆开这些东西的时候必须告诉你一件事，我们确实收到了你第一批送的钥匙扣。现在我们每个人都有你送的两个钥匙扣了。耶。我们太喜欢了。我的上面刻着一句简短的话：“一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。”我太喜欢了。我的上面写着：“女士，谢谢你带给我们所有的欢笑。希望有一天能在现实生活中见到你，这样你就能像老朋友一样跟我唠嗑了。”哦，我太喜欢了。太棒了。我还收到了本和莎拉送的一些礼物。他们有一家公司叫“Just Be”。就是B-E。他们送了，
Angela, you, I have a candle. It smells so good. And Sam and Cassie, you each get a little diffuser. One of them is white birch, and one of them is peony and mahogany. Do you guys have a choice? Cassie, which one do you want? I'll go white birch. Sorry, Sam. She's closest to the mic, Sam. She gets to pick.
安吉拉，你有一个蜡烛。闻起来太香了。萨姆和卡茜，你们俩每人一个小扩香器。一个是白桦木味的，另一个是牡丹与红木味的。你们有得选吗？卡茜，你想要哪一个？我选白桦木。对不起，萨姆。她离麦克风最近，萨姆。她先挑。
Oh, it smells so good. And I also have some treats. I had to bring in some Garrett's popcorn. For all of us, you guys know about Garrett's popcorn, right? No. No. What? We don't.
哦，闻起来太香了。我还带了一些小零食。我必须带点加勒特爆米花（Garrett's popcorn）来。为了我们大家，你们都知道加勒特爆米花吧，对吧？不知道。不知道。什么？我们不知道。
I'm not making it up. Oh, my gosh. Yeah, I know Garrett's popcorn. popcorn. I love Garrett's popcorn. What? Thank you. It is the perfect mixture of sweet and salty. Yes, this is it. Thank you. Thank you. My pleasure. Jenna feels so validated. Cassie and I were like, nope. Okay, they're famous for their like caramel corn, their cheese popcorn, their regular popcorn, but the Chicago mix is where you mix the cheese and the caramel together. What? That's the one that I became slightly obsessed with, and that's one
我没瞎编。哦，天哪。对，我知道加勒特爆米花。我太爱加勒特爆米花啦。什么？谢谢。它是甜味和咸味的完美结合。对，就是这个。谢谢。谢谢。不客气。珍娜觉得太有共鸣了。我和卡茜之前都说：“不。”好吧，他们家最出名的是焦糖爆米花、芝士爆米花、原味爆米花，但“芝加哥混合味”是把芝士和焦糖混在一起。什么？就是那个让我有点欲罢不能的口味，这也是我
I brought back for you guys. Jeez and care. I can't wait to try. Okay. Don't worry. Okay. Also, this gal from Germany brought us all German chocolates. She brought them all the way to Chicago, but she didn't sign her name on the card.
给你们带的那个。芝士加焦糖。我等不及要尝尝了。好吧。别担心。好吧。另外，有个德国姑娘给我们所有人都带了德国巧克力。她一路把它们带到了芝加哥，但她没有在卡片上署名。
But here's what she did right. Quote, Dear Office Ladies' team, you've been good this year. So German Christmas came early, signed Belshnichel, who, by the way, is not a thing in Germany, L-O-L. All right. Well, I have a few things I wanted to share, too. First of all, from the convention, I wanted to read a card that we got in its address to Angela, Jenna, Cassie, and Sam.
但她做得很对的一点是，引述一下：“亲爱的《办公室女士》团队，你们今年表现很好。所以德国圣诞节提前到了，署名：贝尔茨尼克（Belshnichel）。”顺便说一句，这个梗在德国根本不存在，笑死。好吧。嗯，我也有几样想跟大家分享的东西。首先，关于这次粉丝见面会，我想读一张我们收到的卡片，收信人是安吉拉、珍娜、卡茜和萨姆。
And it's from Rachel N. And here's what she had to say. Angela Jenna, Sam and Cassie, thank you all for the Office Ladies' podcast. You're creating such a fun and interesting show that brightens up my day as well as countless others. I originally started listening because I'm a big fan of the office, plus a huge sucker for anything behind the scenes. I started off a fan of the show and have since become an even bigger fan of you all.
署名是瑞秋·N。她是这么说的：安吉拉、珍娜、萨姆和卡茜，谢谢你们带来《办公室女士》播客。你们创作了一个如此有趣且引人入胜的节目，点亮了我的每一天，也点亮了无数其他人的生活。我最初开始听是因为我是《办公室》的超级粉丝，而且对任何幕后花絮都完全没有抵抗力。一开始我是节目的粉丝，后来成了你们所有人的超级粉丝。
It's so cool getting to hear from so many of the cast and crew members and getting to know you all as human beings in such a relaxed and down-to-earth manner. This podcast has brought the show home. It's so evident how much of a family you all are. Your on-screen chemistry was always incredible, but your real-life chemistry is refreshing. I know nothing about creating a podcast, but there has to be so much work going into it from all of you. Thank you for putting in the time and energy as well as your hearts and souls. Listening always boosts my mood. Rachel.
能听到那么多演员和剧组成员的分享，并以如此轻松、接地气的方式了解你们作为普通人的一面，这太酷了。这个播客把这部剧带回了现实。显而易见，你们就像一个大家庭。你们在银幕上的化学反应一直不可思议，但你们现实生活中的化学反应更让人耳目一新。我对制作播客一无所知，但你们所有人为此一定付出了巨大的心血。谢谢你们投入的时间和精力，还有你们的真心与灵魂。收听节目总能让我的心情变好。瑞秋。
Thanks, Rachel. Is that a great card? Yeah, that's really sweet. I just love that. I got a lot of cards and notes from people as well, and it was really sweet. They would say, I didn't want to forget what I wanted to tell you. I read them all and they just, they were really touching. Yeah.
谢谢瑞秋。这不是一张很棒的卡片吗？对，真的很贴心。我太喜欢了。我也收到了很多粉丝的卡片和便签，真的非常贴心。他们会说：“我可不想忘掉我想对你说的话。”我把它们都读了，它们真的、真的很触动人心。对。
Well, we also got a lot of gifts at the convention. I'm going to list a few, like these napkins with stitching that say, Cassie sass. What? What's up, Sam? You got some Sam sass. And then also, Jenna, Sarah from Gig Harbor, Washington made us the most adorable crochet dolls of our The Office characters. She also said if she were asked the call sheet questions, her answer for, tell us a place you've been to that you absolutely loved. She would tell us to go to Monteverde in Costa Rica. She said there is a hummingbird gallery with dozens of feeders and hundreds of hummingbirds gather there. I looked at it. I looked at it. up and oh my God, I want to go. Wow. Great. And then from my cookbook tour, I have to share with you, lady, I met a gal named Leah. She's so talented, and she made us these gorgeous necklaces. On her card, she said, and I quote, office ladies has been my happy place for years. Is that so sweet? Yes. I also have lots of other gifts and cards from the convention, and I have a whole box for you, Jenna. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Everybody. I absolutely.
嗯，我们在见面会上也收到了很多礼物。我挑几样列举一下，比如这些绣着“卡茜的辣妹作风”（Cassie sass）的餐巾纸。什么？怎么了，萨姆？你也有“萨姆的辣妹作风”（Sam sass）。然后还有，珍娜，来自华盛顿州吉格港的莎拉给我们做了最可爱的钩针玩偶，还原了我们《办公室》里的角色。她还说，如果让她回答通告单上的问题，关于“告诉我们一个你去过并且绝对深爱的地方”，她的答案会是让我们去哥斯达黎加的蒙特韦尔德（Monteverde）。她说那里有一个蜂鸟长廊，有几十个喂鸟器，成百上千只蜂鸟聚集在那里。我查了一下。我查了一下，天哪，我想去。哇。太棒了。然后从我的烹饪书巡回签售会开始，我必须跟你分享一下，女士，我遇到了一位叫莉亚的姑娘。她太有才了，给我们做了这些漂亮的项链。她在卡片上说，引述一下：“《办公室女士》多年来一直是我的快乐源泉。”是不是太甜了？是的。我还有很多来自见面会的其他礼物和卡片，我为你准备了整整一箱，珍娜。哦，谢谢。谢谢。大家。我绝对
loved my stage door meet and greets. It sounds like you guys had a great time at the convention and Angela on your cookbook tour. Well, before we wrap up here, I want to give a few shoutouts. We all do to everyone we met at the convention. It's such a big event. And it really wouldn't be possible without the amazing people that work and volunteer at it. So special shout out to them, to the people at my booth, Kat and Betty Jean, to Arnold for organizing the convention. And to Randy, She sent me so many pictures. Thank you, Randy. Yeah, everyone was so cool and kind.
太爱我的后台出口粉丝见面会了。听起来你们在见面会以及安吉拉的烹饪书巡回签售会上都过得很开心。好吧，在我们结束之前，我想对大家表示感谢。我们所有人都要感谢我们在见面会上遇到的每个人。这是一个如此盛大的活动。如果没有在那里工作和做志愿者的了不起的人们，这是绝对不可能实现的。所以要特别感谢他们，感谢我展位上的卡特和贝蒂·让，感谢组织这次见面会的阿诺德。还要感谢兰迪，她发给我了好多照片。谢谢你，兰迪。对，每个人都太酷、太友好了。
And I actually interviewed Betty Jean, who Angela mentioned earlier. She used to cosplay as Pam. Here's her sharing her experience as volunteer. My name is Betty Jean. I'm from Brooklyn, New York. Great. And how long have you been volunteering for the office convention? This is my second year of volunteering.
我其实采访了贝蒂·让，就是安吉拉刚才提到的人。她以前经常cosplay成帕姆。这是她分享自己作为志愿者的经历。我叫贝蒂·让。我来自纽约布鲁克林。太棒了。你为《办公室》粉丝见面会做志愿者多久了？这是我做志愿者的第二年。
I've attended all for the first two I was cosplay as Pam. And then I just got a glimpse of all of the, love and labor that goes into the convention behind the scenes, and I was delighted to find out that they were open for volunteers. So it's been the greatest volunteer gig of my life. That's awesome. So what is it like being a volunteer? I mean, it really boils down to going where you're needed. You never know what's going to happen from you might get placed handling admissions. You might be dealing with merchandise. You might be welcoming vendors. You might be a celebrity handler and helping, you know, hold space for really amazing interactions between fans
我参加了所有的见面会，前两次我都cosplay成了帕姆。然后我有幸窥见了见面会幕后所倾注的所有爱与心血，我很高兴地发现他们招募志愿者。所以这是我一生中最棒的志愿者经历。太棒了。那么，当志愿者是什么感觉？我的意思是，这其实归结为哪里需要你就去哪里。你永远不知道会发生什么，你可能会被安排负责门票检票。你可能需要处理周边商品。你可能需要迎接供应商。你可能会成为艺人统筹（celebrity handler），帮忙维护好空间，确保粉丝和他们来见
and the casting crew that they came to meet. So you never know, there's never a dull moment, but I've gotten so many stories out of this. I'm a minister by trade, so I'm constantly writing stories and discernments, including about humor affecting our life. And I can't even believe just the thousands of stories that I've gotten to hear at this convention,
的演员及剧组成员之间能够进行非常精彩的互动。所以你永远猜不到，这里从来没有无聊的时刻，我从这段经历中收获了超级多的故事。我的本职工作是牧师，所以我一直在写故事和感悟，包括关于幽默如何影响我们的生活。我甚至不敢相信，我在这次见面会上听到了成千上万个故事，
fans pouring their heart out to the casting crew themselves about how the show has changed their lives, how it's had, you know, a decades-long impact on them. So this is the stuff I live for. And now being able to pay it forward for other fans and help create the space. It's amazing. Oh, isn't that special? I love what she said about collecting stories as a minister.
粉丝们向演员和剧组成员倾诉这部剧是如何改变了他们的生活，它是如何对他们产生长达数十年的影响的。所以这就是我活着的动力。现在能够把这份爱回馈给其他粉丝并帮助创造这个空间。这太棒了。哦，这不是很特别吗？我喜欢她作为一名牧师收集故事的说法。
I think that's so cool. I just love that she volunteers. Did you know that theater ushers are also volunteers? No, I didn't know that. Yes. Most theater ushers, that's a volunteer thing. And they do that in exchange for getting to see the plays and musicals for free. I would have done that for sure. Yeah, so everybody, be nice to your ushers. Yeah, they're volunteering.
我觉得这太酷了。我太喜欢她去做志愿者了。你知道剧院引座员其实也是志愿者吗？不，我不知道。是的。大多数剧院的引座员，那都是志愿者工作。他们做这个是为了换取免费看话剧和音乐剧的机会。我绝对愿意干这个。对，所以大家，对你们的引座员好一点。对，他们是做志愿者的。
Exactly. And put your phones away. Well, yeah. So that they don't have to crack down. For sure. Well, before we go, Cassie, I know there was one last thing that you wanted to share with us. And I'm actually so curious about it. You hinted at it.
没错。把你们的手机收起来。对啊。这样他们就不用管得那么严了。确实。好吧，在我们离开之前，卡茜，我知道你还有最后一件事想和我们分享。其实我对此超级好奇的。你之前暗示过我。
Yeah. About it to me. So go ahead. It was like my favorite question that I always asked at the end of every interview. and it was Scott's Tots. Do you watch it or skip it? So many people tell me they skip it. Oh, we did such a great breakdown of it too with B.J. NoFack. I know. I know.
对，跟我提过。所以说吧。这就像是我在每次采访结束时最喜欢问的一个问题，那就是斯科特的 Tots（Scott's Tots）。你是看还是跳过？好多人都告诉我他们跳过了。哦，我们之前和B·J·诺瓦克（B.J. Novak）一起对这一集做过超级精彩的剖析呢。我知道。我知道。
Well, what did people say? Yeah, so all of the responses were so different. So I made like a little compilation and here it is. Scott's Tots, do you watch it or skip it? It's the only episode I skip. I definitely watch it. It's like one of the funniest episodes. How could you not watch it?
那大家怎么说？对，所以所有的回答都不尽相同。所以我做了一个小合集，内容如下。斯科特的 Tots，你是看还是跳过？这是我唯一跳过的一集。我绝对看。这简直是最好笑的几集之一。你怎么能不看呢？
You know, it completely depends on the mood, but I'm going to say skip. Sometimes I skip it, but other times I don't, because Stanley's reaction to that whole thing is just beyond. It's so funny. Oh, no, I watch. That is a painful episode to watch. It is hard to watch. It is hard to watch. I watch it, but I cringe.
你知道的，这完全取决于当时的心情，但我选跳过。有时我跳过，但有时我不跳，因为斯坦利对整件事的反应简直绝了。太搞笑了。哦，不，我看。那一集看的时候太痛苦了。确实很难看。真的很痛苦。我看，但我会脚趾抠地。
And you? Yeah, I watch it. Watch it. You never skip an episode. Even if you're, like, cringing, you're like, oh, Michael, why? Oh, I watch it. I know, yeah, there's a cringe factor for sure, but it's like, you know, that's just part of it. Both. I watch it and skip it. Depends on your mood. It's on the day, yep.
你呢？对，我看。看。你绝不会跳过任何一集。哪怕你觉得，比如脚趾抠地，你也会想，哦，迈克尔，为什么？哦，我看。我知道，对，确实有让人尴尬的成分，但你知道的，这只是其中的一部分。两者兼有。我看也会跳过。取决于你的心情。看当天的状态，对。
I definitely watch it. It's like one of the funniest episodes. How could you not watch it? In between. In between, depends on the mood. Watch it, but it's cringy. I watch it and I laugh. I think it's pretty funny. I watch everything. You can't be a fan and skip anything. That's just how it is. You got to get through it. Watch, obviously, in my Scott's T-Tot's T-shirt. Oh, love it. So it sounds like more watchets than skips it.
我绝对看。这简直是最好笑的几集之一。你怎么能不看呢？介于两者之间。介于两者之间，取决于心情。看，但确实很尴尬。我看，而且我笑得很开心。我觉得挺搞笑的。我什么都看。你不能当个粉丝却跳过任何内容。事情就是这样。你得硬着头皮看完。当然是看，穿着我的斯科特的 Tots T恤。哦，太爱了。所以听起来看的人比跳过的人多。
I think I relate more to the people that are like, it depends on the day. Well, a big thank you to everyone who showed up to meet us and shared with us about their love of the office and office ladies. I really love and treasure this community of folks so much. Yeah, thank you. And thank you, Jim McDermott, for talking to Cassie. and sharing about your experience of working as a set dresser and just hello right back at you. And also, thank you to everyone who waited at the stage door after Ashland Avenue. You were all so polite and patient and kind when I would go to take a selfie with someone,
我觉得我更能共情那些说“取决于当天的状态”的人。好吧，非常感谢所有出现并与我们见面，分享他们对《办公室》和《办公室女士》热爱的每一个人。我真的非常热爱并珍视这个充满伙伴的社区。对，谢谢你们。还要谢谢吉姆·麦克德莫特（Jim McDermott）跟卡茜聊天，分享你作为布景师的工作经历，也向你回问好！同时，还要谢谢所有在阿什兰大街演出结束后在后台出口等待的人。你们都非常有礼貌、耐心和善良，每当我去找某个人拍自拍时，
all the other people they would like duck down and get out of the way to make it a good. It was like, it's what you're talking about. It's just like a community of good folks. It was an honor to speak with all of you. So thank you. and in fact, as a way to say thank you for all of your support, Angela and I want to do an office ladies merch giveaway. Angela, tell everybody how it's going to work. Yes, we appreciate you all so much, and we thought it'd be really fun to start doing some merch giveaways.
所有其他人都会自觉地蹲下、让开，好拍出一张好照片。这就好比，这就是你们刚才在谈论的。这就像是一个充满好人的社区。能和你们所有人交流是我的荣幸。所以谢谢大家。事实上，为了感谢大家的所有支持，安吉拉和我想要举办一次《办公室女士》周边大抽奖。安吉拉，告诉大家具体怎么操作。是的，我们非常感激大家，我们觉得开始搞一些周边抽奖一定会非常有趣。
Our first one is going to be a holiday merch box dropping in December. We're going to give away five boxes of goodies. So five different people are going to get one of these merch giveaway boxes. That's right. We're going to announce it on our Instagram, Office Ladies' Pod, when it goes live. So be on the lookout for all the details there. Well, there you go. That is our fan convention and stage door episode. Thank you, Cassie, for compiling all those audio clips and traveling with me to New Jersey. Oh, my goodness. We'll always have New Jersey, Cassie. We'll always have New Jersey. All right, you guys, have a great week. See you later. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
我们的第一个活动是将在十二月推出一个节日周边礼盒。我们将送出五个好礼盒。所以会有五个人分别获得这些周边赠品礼盒。没错。我们将在我们的Instagram账号Office Ladies' Pod上公布活动上线消息。请密切关注那里的所有细节。好了，这就是我们的粉丝见面会和后台探秘单集。谢谢卡西整理了所有这些音频片段并和我一起去了新泽西。哦，天哪。我们永远都会拥有新泽西，卡西。我们永远都会拥有新泽西。好了，各位，祝大家过个愉快的一周。再见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。